[ Applause ]
>> Good morning, Krakow. My
name east Michael, I am Irish.
I work in the office.  Google
is a fun place for engineers to
work and helped to create
products that have a really
global impact.  But before I get
into the talk, I want you to
think a bit about what end users
of Google products think about
Google.  Probably the first
thing thing about is Google's
search engine.  And then I want
you to think about what sort of
company is Google?  What are we?
We're one of the biggest
companies in the world in terms
of revenues and market cap and
so on.
But if you think about what sort
of company we are, we started
out as a search company.  But
now we're much more than a
search company.  People in this
audience probably have a good
idea of what we are.  We're a
company that produces a lot of
products.  And all of these
products are this strange new
thing that didn't exist a
hundred years ago -- software
products.  Strangely ephemeral
based on layers of abstraction
that keep changing every five
years or every two months if
you're in JavaScript.
Now, the -- if you think about
what it takes to build these
products, essentially this means
that we're a software company.
And so we know about software,
and we love our own developers
and we love you, our developer
community.  So this means that
our products are more than just
products -- they're things that
people use to help create real
impact globally.  And every one
of our hundreds of products has
potentially billions of success
stories of people using them to
really change their lives.  And
very importantly, in terms of
Google's philosophy, even though
we started as an American
company in Silicon Valley like
many other software companies,
from the get-go, our vision has
been a global  vision.
And our vision has been that the
Internet and the services and
products that we provide, are
for absolutely everyone on the
planet.  Not just for English
speakers.  Not just for North
Americans.  Not just for
Europeans -- but globally.  And
we've put a huge amount of
investment of time and effort
and energy into trying to make
this vision real.  And we
certainly have gone a long way
there.  If you look at the
globe, we have users in all
corners of the globe using all
of our products.
Now, I'm going to focus in on
what we're doing here in Europe
in terms of engineering.
Because you may think that our
engineering products are all
developed in America.  But, in
fact, we're a global company and
we have a very, very
significant presence here in
Europe.  The dots represent our
engineering offices, not all of
our offices, in  AMEA.  Europe,
the Middle East and Africa.
Includes Zurich, Dublin, Munich,
Paris, Stockholm and Warsaw and
Tel Aviv in Israel.  Famously
Google has seven products that
have more than a billion users
and some of them with more than
2 billion users.  And every one
of these products has a
significant engineering effort
here in Europe.
At its simplest, there's two
main types of engineers in
Google.  There are what we call
"SWEs," software engineers.  And
there are what we call"  SREs,"
site reliability engineers.
Because so many of our products
are hosted Internet services, we
need to place just as much
emphasis on keeping  things up
and running, so on and so forth,
as we go on actually building
and developing the
software itself.  It takes both
types of engineers to keep it
going.  And the whole slew of
engineers includes UX and design
and all types of security and
all sorts of things.  But
principlely Google thinks of
these engineers as falling into
these two categories.  If you
think about where some of this
activity takes place, just to
call out three.  Android has a
huge base in London.  Chrome has
a huge base in Paris and
London.  And Play has a big base
in London and in Zurich.  Now,
as well as creating products for
consumers, we also create
products for developers.
And there's a number of
different types of products that
we create for developers.  So
probably the most obvious one --
which has a huge presence at
this event -- is the Google
Cloud Platform.  And much of
that effort takes place here in
Poland in Warsaw.  And the next
speaker, Ewa, will be giving
details about what's actually
going on there in that office.
As well as that, we very sort of
APIs that can be reused by
Googles that are part of the
platform, but come from a
separate engineering effort.  In
Europe, a lot of that effort is
focused in Zurich.  After Ewa,
we have
Behshad talking about it.  And
you can use AI in your own
services.
We have a set of external
developer tools that we link to
the Google Cloud Platform.  And
because we need to support them,
we have a set of internal
developer tools.  And a lot of
that effort goes on in my home
office in Munich.  And then we
have, like any company does,
corporate applications that are
for all users, not just for
developers.  And a lot of that
effort happens in Munich and
London.  And why do we do all
this?  So that you have the
tools to build cool products and
services for your own users.
Now, as this is mainly a
developer audience, I just to
want give you a bit of a feel
about the scale that we operate
in our own software inside
Google.  For comparison, let's
just look at the Linux 4.2 code
base.  Roughly 29 million lines
of code in 50,000 files.  Quite
a big code base.  We changed
that amount of code in our code
base in Google every week.  In
fact, more than that number of
files gets changed every week.
If you look at the bigger stats,
internally we have more than
40,000 developers working on a
single integrated monocode base
that's made up of a billion
files and 9 million source files
and 2 billion lines of code.
And we're working furiously at
this every day.  And code review
is a critical part of Google's
code culture.  So we have over
20,000 code reviews happening
per workday.  Nobody is allowed
to check stuff into the master
repo without it being reviewed
on a number of different vectors
.
And this leads to thousands of
commits per  week.  And
interestingly, over time we've
invested so much in our internal
tooling that there's a much
huer growth rate of automated
changes to our code base than
the human-based changes.  But
also quite interestingly, these
automated changes also seem to
have breaks in the holidays,
right?  So the robots take
holidays too.
Our tooling is vast.  We've
invested very, very heavily in
it.  And the tooling group they
work for is called Dev Task
Developer Tools and Signals.
We're in charge of this internal
tooling for internal code base
that we call Google 3.  And
there's a set of probably 20 to
50 tools in these various
categories that help build our
software and keep it currently
and keep it regular.  I want to
call out just one of these tools
that we've  externalized as
open source.  It's a tool called
Basel.  It will be interesting
to you working on large code
bases and you want to optimize
build  times because it allows
you to store a graph of all the
builds that anyone in the
company has done.  And if you
can cache those builds, when the
builds are then done again,
only the stuff that hasn't
already been compiled needs to
be recompiled and you can reuse
the binaries from anywhere in
the  organization.  And we use a
version of this had internally
in Google called
"Blaze."  And it's one of the
core productivity tools that we
have.  Now,  Basal is open
source and not yet version 1.0.
But already being used by
companies like Dropbox and
Stripe.  So especially you're
working on large code bases, you
might be really interested in
Basal.
In terms of our philosophy, we
have a slightly unique way of
doing things in Google using our
single monorepo.  It's our own
tool called Piper.  Again, one
of my teams works on that.  We
of the static sitessed off using
per force and we needed to
build our own replacement for it
.  Mandatory code reviews, fast
builds from source at head using
Blaze, ruthless
refactoring and identifying
breaking changes with automated
testing.  Maintaining a green
build and frequent releases.  In
fact, anything  running in our
own internal cloud that's
running for more than six months
without an update is a red flag
and people have to revisit it.
This is to make sure that we're
constantly recompiling all of
our  services with the latest
libraries to make sure we're not
opening any vulnerabilities.
If you look at the news today,
anyone who develops in Java,
check out the struts
vulnerability that was just
announced.  It's quite scary.
You may be recompiling some code
tonight.  So to take it all
back, then, we are trying to
invest in software.  We have an
internal community and we have
an external community.  And
we're trying to take as much
knowledge from our internal
community to share with the
external community in terms of
tools, services and products.
And now we've realized that we
need to also invest in
communication and events like
this.  And this event is one
example of this, trying to hold
-- host more events here in
Europe where -- as was mentioned
in the opening keynote on day
one -- we know there there are
more software developers than in
North America, U.S. and Canada
combined.  Last month we had the
Polymer Summit in Copenhagen in
Denmark.  And next month, the
Firebase Summit in Amsterdam,
the Netherlands.  It's cool how
you can cook up the Firebase
with cloud functions from the
Google Cloud Platform to create
a lightweight, serverless,
backend to very complex
applications.  And any who work
mobile might be interested in
that.
So I'm now going to pass you
over to someone who will do a
deeper dive into the Google
Cloud Platform and who works
here in Europe,Ewa, who works in
our Warsaw office.  Thank you.
[ Applause ]
EWA: Thank you.  Hello.  My name
is Ewa Macias.  And I'm leading
Cloud frontend team.  One of
the engineering teams we have in
Poland.  I'm very happy to be
here today in Krakow.  I counted
and I spent about 43% of my
entire life in Krakow.  And 88%
of my adult life.  I was
studying here and then spent the
first eight years at Google
here.  It's really good to be
back.
And I'm proud that I'm
representing our Google Poland
office here today.  And tell you
a little bit about what we are
focusing on.  Over the last
decade, Google Poland has
focused its efforts on technical
infrastructure.  We built
products and systems that are
part of the Google Internet
Platform.  Google services like
search and YouTube and Gmail are
running.  We build software
throughout multiple layers.
From an agent running on every
single machine in Google data
centers through a  massive data
collection and process, to web
user interface.
A major theme for us over the
years has been automation.  And
improving user interaction with
the infrastructure so that the
internal teams can spend less
time doing operations work and
more time developing actual
logic.  Here's one example of
our automation focus.  We build
a system that, for a service,
automatically chooses a data
center to run on based on the
service requirements.  It also
decides how many resources to
allocate for a  service.  And
decides how many copies of the
service to run.  When we get
started here in Poland, over ten
years ago, the industry was
running mostly on private data
centers.  Maintaining large,
specialized servers.  These days
almost everyone is looking at
how to move to Cloud.
Because it's expensive and time-
consuming to maintain
infrastructure.  And it also
takes you away from your core
business.  So for the last four
years we focused our efforts on
exposing the Internet
infrastructure to our external
users.  And the resulting
product is known today as Google
Cloud Platform.  Why developers
choose cloud?  Because it's
built on the same infrastructure
as all  other services at
Google.  And it offers security,
scale and consistency, access
to a global network.  Best in
class data processing tools.
Access to services like machine
learning and most importantly,
velocity.  You can see here on
the slides some quotes directly
from our customers.
I could stand here probably for
all day telling you about GCP,
but since we don't have that
much time, the rest of my talk
will focus on the product known
as Cloud Compute.  This is what
our team in Poland is working on
.  In Cloud Compute, our mission
is to help you find a perfect
engine for your workloads.  From
from serverless environments to
containers to machines, we are
working to create a range of
options to match your needs.
Specifically, Cloud Compute
offers four places where you can
run your software.  Compute
engine, container engine, app
engine and cloud functions.
Now, when I look at this slide,
maybe Cloud functioning should
be we named to engine, the slide
would look much better then.
Look at the slide as at a
spectrum.   The lower in the
stack, the more flexibility and
control you have.  The higher in
the stack, the more automation
Google provides.  In other words
, in the lower layer, you get
almost no infrastructure.  In
the highest layer, you just
bring your code, your business
logic, and Google will do the
rest for you.
I'm going to walk you through
the four  platforms to give you
an understanding of what they
are and how you might want to
use them.  And I will also point
out some specific things that
we are working on here in
Poland.  So let's start from the
bottom.  Compute Engine.
Compute Engine offers virtual
machines.  Think of virtual
machines as your personal
computer.  Only that it's not on
your desk but that it's remote.
It's in a Google data center
and you can access it remotely
.  So let me now show you how to
get a server on GC in a few
seconds.
I will do a live demo, so
fingers crossed.
So this is Cloud Console.
It's a web interface where you
can create and manage your GCP
resources.  It's a really good
place to start exploring the
platform.  See here I've got
four platforms I'm presenting
today.  But you can get access
to many more like storage and
networking and machine learning
-- everything.  So let's go to
the Compute Engine.  And create
an instance.  When you -- when
you create an instance you can
decide how big it is.  You can
get anything from one core to 64
cores.  And you can get up to
416 gigabytes of memory.  We
have a wide range of pre-cooked
images.  Linux distributions and
Windows Server.  You can also
bring your own image.
If you want this instance to run
with traffic, you will probably
enable HTTP/HTTPS.  By default,
all are protected by firewalls
from the traffic from the
Internet.  Before I go ahead and
create this VM I want to show
you one cool thing.  Many users,
when they get more familiar
with GCP, they tend to prefer
command line over the UI.  And
it's natural process.  But this
web UI  is a very good way to
learn command line tool and
transition to command line
later.  For almost everything
that you can do in this UI, you
can get in the valid command
line.  This is the command line
for the VM.  And the cool thing
is that you can run it directly
from the browser.  Whoops.
So we don't have to restart the
Cloud or configure anything on
your computer.  All you need is
the browser.  So let's go ahead
and create a VM.  Putting the VM
and programming the network
takes like 20, 30 seconds.  And
so there's one more cool thing I
want to show.  So when you have
the server up and running, you
want to SSH to it and you want
to -- and you can start
installing basically any
software you like on the server.
And you can also  SSH directly
from the UI.  Okay.
It will take a couple of
seconds.  Maybe I will be
waiting for that.  Okay.  Black
screen.  I don't know what
happened.  Okay.  Okay.  Let's
go -- okay.  We are in the --
inside of the VM and you can,
you know, start browsing as a
normal virtual machine.  I
really also wanted to do this
demo, because the frontend for
Cloud Compute is being built in
Warsaw.
[ Applause ]
one thing that I would like to
point out is that sometimes it
can be hard to decide up front
what is the right size of the
machine for your service.  To
help with that, GCP will observe
the load of the VM and the
traffic and will recommend you
the best size.  Either decrease
it to save you money, or
increase it for a better
performance.  This
recommendation engine is being
built in Poland as well.
[ Applause ]
Together with the V Ms and
access to a global network, you
also get a set of tools that
help you manage the service.
One of them is auto-scaling
groups of instances.  You can
configure it so it always keeps
a certain amount of instances up
and running.  The system does
it by observing the health and
re-creating the VM if they go
unhealthy.  You can also attach
an auto-scaler that will observe
the CPU load and add or remove
the servers based on your metric
or on the traffic on the CPU
load.  So you still have full
control offer what is running on
the VM, but you apply an
automation that helps you run
the service in a cost-efficient
and reliable way.  And
auto-scaler and many other tools
that help you manage GCP are
also being built in Poland.
[ Applause ]
All right.  Let's go one little
up to Container  Engine.
Container Engine is our hosted
Kubernetes environment.  And you
might guess from its name, it's
a platform running a large
number of  containers.  It
handles a lot of infrastructure
for you like virtual machines
and networking.  And by using
the open source Kubernetes, it
also manages the containers for
you automatically.  What are
containers?  I like thinking
about containers as a lighter
version of virtual machines.
They're software packaging units
that only take your code and
libraries and make them
independent from the operating
system so that you can run
multiple containers on one VM in
isolation.
Unlike virtual machines, they do
not contain operating systems.
So they are much smaller in
bytes and they start much
faster.  What are Kubernetes?
Usually put just one thing into
a container, like web server or
database, for example.  So when
you want to start building a
system out of your containers,
you usually end up having a lot
of them.  And maintaining a lot
of containers can be
challenging.  So let me give you
one example.  Let's say I want
to have a three layers data
application.  Database, backend
and frontend.  So I package them
into three containers.  For
redundancy, I want to have a
couple of instances of each.  I
want to have a frontend
accessible by a static IP
address.  And two layers.  And
even with this simple service,
it can be challenging to
maintain.  So here's where
Kubernetes comes in.
They will start that app for you
and make sure it stays up and
running.  Some of you may have
heard or played the game,
Pokemon Go!  This slide will
show how fast the game was
growing in the first days of its
popularity.  So this line shows
the estimated traffic.  The
green line is the disaster
scenario.  And the blue line is
the real traffic.  So it was the
huge success of the game, and
it was also a huge success of
the Google Container Engine
because the platform actually
managed to scale for the game.
And I'm very proud to say that
Google Poland is contributing to
both Kubernetes and GKE, and
specifically they are working on
the platform.
Now let's go another layer up
to App Engine.  It's optimized
to run your web code extremely
well.  The motto of App Engine
is: bring your code, and we'll
do the rest for you.  So you
don't have to think about
operating system or virtual
machines or any other piece of
infrastructure when you use App
Engine.  This is called
serverless environment.  It
doesn't mean that the server
doesn't exist.  It only means
that from the perspective of a
developer, the server is
invisible.  All you see when you
implement and manage and deploy
your app are application-level
tracks.
App Engine also
offers a set of tools crafted
for web productions like traffic
splitting, security scanner, an
incredibly rapid scaling.  The
last piece of our spectrum is
Cloud Functions.  It also is a
serverless environment, but from
the perspective of a developer,
it's even simpler than App
Engine.  And it can be seen as a
glue that enables you to very
easily use many Google services
like vision API or listen for
changes in the database.  With
Cloud Functions you can almost
forget about the conflict of an
application.  All you see or all
you think about when you use
Cloud Functions is your code,
your function.  And then event
on which the functions should be
executed.  So let me show you
how you do it.  A classical
example is sending an email to a
user when they upload an image
to a database.
All right.
So let's go to Cloud
Functions.  I will create a
function, upload an image to a
storage and observe that the
function was executed.  So I
choose a trigger.  Cloud storage
bucket.  I specify the bucket
that will be observed for
changes.  And here is my code.
I will not be sending --
emailing this demo.  We don't
have that much time.  I will
just pretend.
And one small detail.  And
just specify a bucket where my
source code would be  stored.
And create.
Now I will go to the  storage
-- let's see the trigger --
let's go so that we are in the
storage UI.  And I'm loading a
file.  Let's say a dog image.
Please upload.
Okay.  It doesn't want to
upload the file.  Woohoo.  Oh!
Woohoo!  Yes.  The file is
there.
[ Applause ]
Success.  So now let's go and
see whether the function was
executed.  And I go to logs.
Since we are in the source code,
we are logging the fact that
the function has been executed.
And -- all right.  The log is
not there.  Not there yet.  All
right.  We have something.  Do
we have a dog?  We have a  dog.
And we have a cat.  Okay.  So
let's go back to the
presentation.  So you see?  That
was easy.  That was like, a
couple of clicks and lines of
code.  And all the glue between
your code and the storage, in
particular, listening to the
changes, and making sure that
your function is really getting
executed at least once.  Alled
that handled for you by the
platform.  As some of you may
have heard yesterday, Cloud
Functions also can be used with
Firebase and it's a very
powerful way for the mobile
developers to build a server
side extension without having to
learn or manage or understand
any of the -- or deal with any
servers.  And Cloud Functions
are 100% designed and bullet
in Warsaw.
[ Applause ]
All right.  So a quick recap of
the presentation.  When you use
Compute Engine, you think about
people and machines operating
and a network.  Basically,
virtual infrastructure.
Containers take you from the
world of virtual machines to
microservices, containers and
application.  When you use App
Engine, you choose to abstract
away from the infrastructure.
And all you see or hear about is
application and HTTP requests.
And, finally, when you use
Cloud Functions, you saw that it
operates on a piece of code --
your function
function -- and that's it.
Now that I've highlighted the
differences between the four
platforms, you might be asking
yourself.  So which one should I
be using?  My recommendation is
that you go from the top.
Check whether the platforms work
for you and whether it's not
constraining you too much.  And
if it's not, just take it.  If
it is constraining you too much,
it means that you need more
flexibility and control, so go
one level down.
Google Cloud Platform has really
a lot to  offer, and we are
very excited about its future.
So if you are interested in
learning more about it, I
encourage you to go to the Cloud
Console or to  Cloud.google.com
and start exploring.
I also will be around here
today if you want to ask me any
questions.  So now I would like
to introduce my colleague,
Behshad Behzadi from the Zurich
office.  He's a senior
engineering director and he's
leading a team of over 100
engineers building Google
Assistant., Behshad
, on stage.
[ Applause ]
BEHSHAD: Hello, everybody.  My
name is Behshad and I work on
the Google Assistant team in the
Zurich office.  Yesterday Tilke
talked about the different ways
that you can bring Google
Assistant into your own
applications through the actions
in Google Platform.  Today I
want to talk about what we in
Google are doing to improve the
Google Assistant across devices.
So in Google I/O, Sundar sent
this key message, which is the
next ten years is going to be an
AI-first world.  I'm
personally very excited about
that because I consider Google
Assistant and  building an
Assistant is actually one of the
core implementations of such an
AI world.  So in some  ways we
feel that we are part of
building this next revolution.
But before going and talking
more about the Google Assistant
itself, I want to talk about a
little bit about this AI
revolution.  The AI revolution
is in some ways similar to some
of the bigger revolutions in the
past hundred years.  These were
revolutions where they changed
the lives of lots of people.
They made lots of companies
disappear, lots of new companies
appear, and saving lots of time
for people.  If you think about
phone, car, plane and
transistor.  They were
considered a plague.  Going from
the U.S. to Europe, you needed
a month on a ship, and only some
people could do that.  Today,
less than a day, ten hours.
That's about saving time.  Life
of people is changing.
Now, if we move fast forward to
newer types of revolutions which
happened around 20 years ago,
the PC and Internet.  So all of
a sudden at home you get
connected to the information.
So we didn't need to go to the
library if you wanted to find
how tall is the Empire State
Building.  If you think, 20
years ago, that was the only way
to find the answers to such
questions.  This is a big
change, again, into people's
lives.  You don't need to go to
a bank to check what is your
bank account.  You can buy
things from home and don't need
to wait for the next news on TV
to know what the weather is
going to be tomorrow.  You can
just ask it.  But the next
revolution happened soon after,
less than ten years, and that's
the mobile revolution, which was
even bigger than the previous
one.  The huge PC which was in
the corner of your home before
now is replaced by these mobile
phones, which is smaller and in
your pocket and you can bring it
everywhere.  It's actually, in
some ways, more powerful.
It has a camera, it has a
microphone and it's more
personal.  You can take
pictures, share, communicate and
more.
Mobile made our thinking at
Google about productive.  We
became a mobile-first company
from those moments.  However,
the mobile revolution is still
ongoing and we kind of predict
that by 2020 there is going to
be 5 billion mobile users on
this planet, which means that
really the scale is bigger than
the PC and
Internet revolution that was
happening before.  This is
because the cost in an emerging
market is much easier.  This
revolution is ongoing, but the
next revolution is happening now
and bringing this revolution to
the next level.  This is the AI
revolution.  This is where, in
the example of mobiles, we are
trying to make interactions with
mobiles conversational, much
natural.  Make the smartphones
smart and make them to
understand intents and
understand context and answer
things based on what they hear
and what they see.
When we have these
conversational types of
experiences through -- slide is
not changing -- through the --
when we have these experiences
through the -- through a
conversation with mobiles, we
can expand to other devices.  If
you have a car, your watch at
home, you can use the same
conversational experience and
try to add that intelligence in
a very consistent way through
all your devices at -- in
different places.  And now  the
-- I repeatedly say
conversation, conversation, and
this is really the core of what
we think about Google Assistant.
Because we kind of think a
conversation is the most-used
interface human beings have.
The most interface that human
beings have  used.  We know how
to talk from a kid to when we
are old.  But from different
race, different ages.  People
know how to interact with each
other through talking.  So if we
solved that problem of
conversational understanding, we
have solved a big problem and
can expand that in many use
cases.  The best would
be -- I want to show you Google
Assistant.  And I would like to
invite the cameraman to come
and I will go to my live demos,
which is going to be quite risky
for me.  They're all live demos
and you will have fun seeing me
being scared, I guess.
So
here I'm own my phone.  I'm
going to show you lots of demos
of showing where we are.  Where
in Google we are, and different
aspects of what the Assistant is
doing.  So the first thing I
would show is about how Google
Assistant is answering thing
s.  Let's start with, hi,
Google, how are you doing?
>> I'm doing great. Thanks for
asking.  Anything I can help you
with?
>> Can you please tell me how is
the weather going to be
tomorrow in Krakow?  Always --
it's --
[ Applause ]
I don't think it uploaded to
work.  Can you please tell me
how is the weather going to be
tomorrow in Krakow.
>> Partly cloudy.
[ Applause ]
BEHSHAD: So as -- this is a
rather more language, the longer
types of questions.  As opposed
to when you type on a machine,
you say, weather, Krakow,
tomorrow.  Here I use a long
sentence in a conversation way.
We're trying to understand --
there's machine learning behind
which understands that sentence
is the same thing that's weather
in Krakow tomorrow.  So let's
do more questions.  Show me
tourist attractions in Krakow.
>> Awe tractions --
BEHSHAD: Okay.  So this is a
more popular question about
weather or attractions.  But now
I want to show you how we
actually try to expand the
answering capabilities to really
more specific and long type of
questions.  For example, show me
a list of rides
in Europa Park.
>> Silver star, others.
BEHSHAD: We know about the rides
in an attraction park.  I'm
going to ask questions about one
particular ride there.  What is
the height restriction for Blue
Fire?
>> You must be at least one
meter tall to ride.
BEHSHAD: Thanks.  So what I'm
try to show here is the range of
examples that we get.  But we
really are trying to expand to a
long -- wide range of questions
.  And that's what you expect
from an automated Assistant.
Now, the next example I'm
showing you, and actually across
my demos, it's a mixture of
things which is live and
launched, and some of the things
which is not yet launched but
are like internal prototypes
that we have.  And they're going
to launch either in the next
few months -- and in some cases,
next year.  So the next one is
one of them which we are trying
to handle more complex natural
language understanding.
What is the name of the movie
where Tom Cruise acts in it and
he plays pool and while he plays
pool, he dances?
>> Here is the info. Color of
Money --
[ Applause ]
BEHSHAD:
So this is possible through
merging like the power of search
.  The signal is coming from
Google Search, with mission
learning.  It's a combined
system that's capable of doing
these  things.  We consider a
task for example.  So now let me
show you how this voice
interface could be used for
connecting to other services
from first-party Google or some
type of other outside Google.
So first I will show an example
of how the integration would
translate and look like in this
Assistant world.  Be my
Vietnamese translator.
>> Understood. I will translate
all of the following messages
to Vietnamese.  To stop, just
say, stop translation.
BEHSHAD: Hey, I have a problem.
Can you help me?
>> [speaking in Vietnamese]
BEHSHAD: I lost my luggage in
the train.
>> [Speaking in Vietnamese]
BEHSHAD: Stop translation.
>> Okay!
[ Applause ]
BEHSHAD: So you can use this
natural language and talking and
get connected to these services
and applications.  Now, I show
another example, this time with
the street view again to show a
combination of voice input and
the natural language
understanding connected to this
service.  In this case I would
say something like, I would like
to be on the top of the Eiffel
Tower now, can you please bring
me there.
>> Okay.
BEHSHAD: We call this project
internally  "Teleport."  It's --
[ Applause ]
I think that's as good as we can
do for a teleport.  So now I
want to show you how this could
be, for example, with integrated
with a service which is not
developed at Google.  Talk to
WebMD.
>> Sure. Getting webML.
Welcome to WebMD.  I can tell
you about health conditions,
drugs and even side effects.
What would you like to know?
BEHSHAD: What are the side
effects of Aspirin?
>> Here is a list.
BEHSHAD: It actually failed.  We
can try one more time, maybe.
What are the side effects of
Aspirin?
>> Here are --
BEHSHAD: Okay.  But you know it
works.  I guess we are
developing this too.  But really
in the core of what we need is
also to be able to talk to
different services developed by
the Google Platform to the
Assistant itself.  So in the
next part of my demos, I want to
show how the Assistant should
be ultra personal.  This is kind
of a personal assistant.  These
are answers and things which
the Assistant can do about the
world for me, but we want it to
also be answering things which
are spoke me.  For example, I
can do things like, how is the
traffic from Zurich Airport to
my home?
>> There is light traffic on the
way home.
BEHSHAD: So I don't need to say
what is the address of my home.
My Assistant knows that and
that's helpful for me.  I can
ask for things like, when is my
flight today?
>> Your flight is at --
BEHSHAD: So note that these are
all happening automatic and
through a different machine
learning system detecting that
from Gmail.  We have ways to do
explicit in an explicit way.
For example, how is my team
doing?
>> They're only --
BEHSHAD: It's only the
beginning.
[ Applause ]
But these are all -- I think
that's -- these are all the
personal ones I have.  But I
think the reason I can actually
do that is because I explicit
lilysaid this.  Or I can say
what is my favorite team?
>> You told me that you like
Barcelona.  Biggest I liked
Barcelona a few months back, and
when I say how is my team
doing, it considers Barcelona.
Now I want to show you -- this
is a way that we can actually
improve the Assistant by
teaching something to it about
myself.  I'm going to show you a
more fancy version of that
which is coming next year.  When
the weather is more than 25
degrees, I can swim in the Lake
of Zurich.
>> Okay. Understood.
BEHSHAD: Can I swim in the Lake
of Zurich this weekend?
>> No, you can't. The
temperature is less than 25
degrees.
[ Applause ]
BEHSHAD: What's the weather in
Zurich this weekend?
>> Here's the forecast.
BEHSHAD: So that's kind of --
really, if you think about a
personal assistant which you can
improve it through natural
language, this is going to be
much more powerful and easier to
use for many people.  So the
next part of my demo is I want
to talk about context.  Context
is very important.  The
different meanings of context is
used to make the interactions
with the Assistant easier and
more natural.  And we use it in
different place.  One of the
places that we use context is
speech recognition itself.
Trying to understand the words.
So now I try to say an example
where first I don't give it a
context.  Normally it fails.
And then I try to give it
context and see whether it works
or not.  Something like, how
high is the rice?
>> Here you go.
BEHSHAD: How high is the rice?
So the point here is that I
don't -- if context -- it's hard
to even hand it sometimes.
>> Here is the weather in Zurich
.
BEHSHAD: It tries to do
something because it dunce
understand what it says.  Now
let's see if I give some context
to it.  Highest Tatra mountain
s.  So as you see now, there is
a Rysy there.  And now I will
ask and hopefully it should
work.  How high is the Rysy?
>> I can search the web for
answers.
BEHSHAD: Highest Tatra mountains
.  How high is the Rysy?
>> The Rysy is --
[ Applause ]
BEHSHAD: So this shows that
contextual voice recognition is
actually going to play a big
role.  Because people actually
always try to continue talking
about things which is related
and things which are also
personal and location-specific
and contextually relevant.  Now
let me show you another use of
context when context is used to
understand the entities itself.
For example, pictures of
Thomas.  I think without a
context, that's perhaps the best
we can come up with.  Bayern
Munich team roster.
>> The roster for Bayern Munich
.  Bogey see
BEHSHAD:  you see Thomas is
here.  Pictures of Thomas.  So
in the context of --
[ Applause ]
In the context of the previous
sentence, then Thomas should be
interpreted as a different
entity in this case.  Now, I
want to show you how context is
helping to have
conversations.  Something like,
where is the Empire State
Building.
>> The Empire State Building in
New York, New York.
BEHSHAD: I want to see pictures.
>> Pictures of the Empire State
Building, okay.
BEHSHAD: How tall is it?
>> The Empire State Building is
443 meters
tall.
BEHSHAD: Who built it?
>> Saret
t Corporation.
BEHSHAD: When?
>> 1930.
BEHSHAD:
what are the Italian
restaurants around there?
>> I found these places.
BEHSHAD: Call the first one.
It's in New York.  So you can
see that I'm having a
conversation back and forth with
-- I will stop there.
[ Applause ]
So you can see that I have like
seven, ought sentences about the
Empire State Building I
mentioned only one time.  This
is through the power of context
and trying to put context in the
conversational understanding.
This is closer to how people
talk.  Still, there are lots of
problems Tor solved there, but
we are excited about the steps
in the right direction.  Still,
I want to show another example
of context, which is the context
of what you see.  So for that
I'm basically trying to show
some examples of Google lens
with the Assistant where we are
adding visual input to the
Assistant.  I don't know what
you're seeing here.  I'm putting
an apple here.  And I'm going
to the Google Lens part of the
Assistant.  And I would ask, how
many calories does it have?
>> There are 95 calories in one
medium apple.
BEHSHAD: So that's the --
[ Applause ]
This is an experience that you
can have where you have visual
input and voice input together.
So let me show you one other
example.  I can try to get some
money.  The input.  Okay.
Okay.  This is -- yeah.  How
much is this in Swiss
Franc?
>> 250 --
[ Applause ]
BEHSHAD: So you can see that --
and this combination can be very
useful.  I was actually walking
in Krakow yesterday seeing
buildings and  trying to go
through Google Lens and ask
questions about what was around.
That's going to be a more
powerful experience for the
future of the Assistant.  The
last example I want to show you
is -- the speech recognition
often worked here.  I want to
show you we have worked on
improving the speech recognition
in a noisy environment.  I want
your help.  And the setup is we
will cut your mic, and you will
make as much noise as you can.
You want to make me fail.  I
will ask when my favorite team
is playing next.  And we can put
some music to make the noise to
be  higher.  It's okay if I
fail.  It's just fun.  Let's do
it.
So please make as much noise as
you can, and please cut the mic.
[Crowd making noise
]
Can you have the mic?  We have
to spend lots of time on trying
to improve the speech
recognition in a announcey
environment.  Added lots of data
to the systems behind with the
automatically generated noise
like fake noise of a stadium or
people or  cars.  And that's how
we have significantly managed
to improve this.  Thank you, the
cameraman.  So I can go back to
my slides for -- thank you.
[ Applause ]
So what you have seen in the
previous days in these demos is
actually lots of technologies
going behind.  A lot of it's
being built in Zurich, in
Europe.  Speech recognition,
understanding natural language,
understanding the world,
understanding the user,
understanding the context, image
recognition and
personalization.  And many more.
But these were the ones that I
put on the slides.  And this is
all -- these are all early
steps of the Google Assistant
and the age of the Assistant.
But it's a very exciting moment.
I want to remind you that I
talked about AI revolution, and
that doesn't mean Google
Assistant or age of assistant is
the AI revolution.  It's one of
the things which is happening
in this AI revolution.  The AI
and machine learning is being
used heavily and going to be
used much many in many
industries such as health,
agriculture, smart cities, smart
cars and many more.  It's time
to invest in different
industries in the  AI.  And
while at Google we're -- I'm
working -- and we're working on
the Google Assistant, I feel
very excited about adding these
types of intelligences into the
Google Assistant.  But I think
in the end the Google Assistant
will be more powerful depending
on how many different services
and applications it can have.
And this is where you all can
help by integrating with a
Google Assistant with the
different use cases that you
have and applications that you
have.  And take part with us in
building this AI revolution.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
And I would like to invite
Michael back to the stage.
[ Applause ]
MICHAEL: So we've had two great
talks to kick off the day today.
And I would especially like to
thank those two speakers,
Behshad who is very brave with
all those demonstrations --
thank you.
[ Applause ]
And Ewa who showed us the very
exciting work that's going on in
Warsaw in Poland.
[ Applause ]
I was reminded of one of my
favorite geeky  T-shirts as I
was listening to Ewa, which is,
there's no such thing as cloud
computing.  Only someone else's
computers.  And the thing is,
when that is true, you want the
people running those computers
to know what they're doing.  And
so trust in Google.  Use our
Google Cloud Platform.
Now, I'd advise you all to make
best use of the  Codelabs that
allow you to sort of do
follow-up activities, especially
on the Google Cloud Platform
stuff that Ewa was talking
about.  But also the open
sourced stuff that relates to
what Behshad was talking about.
And for the rest of the day you
can join in sessions and
trainings and explore the
sandboxes scattered around.  And
don't forget,  wrapping up at a
quarter past five, 17:15, back
here in the main auditorium with
the closing keynote.  Thanks
very much, and enjoy the rest of
the conference.
[ Applause ]
FLORINA: Hello, everyone.  My
name is Florina Muntenescu.  I'm
a developer at Google.  At
Google I/O earlier this year we
launched architecture
components.  A collection of
libraries that help you design
robust, testable and
maintainable apps.   Since then
we have been discussing with a
lot of  you.  And then we saw a
lot of the requests that kept on
repeating.  Stuff like, okay,
I'm already using Java in my
application.  Should I start
using live beta also?  Or my
architecture is implemented and
you're saying MVP, should I move
to MVVM?  Or I need to display
a large list.  What should I
do?  I want to tell you our
suggestions of how to handle all
of these.
But before I go into this, I
want to go a little bit over the
architecture components just to
make sure that we're all on the
same page.  And also I want to
mention a few of these dos and
don'ts of the of the
architecture components.  So
let's say that this is an
activity that displays
information about the user.  One
of the biggest problems for us
and our developers is
configuration change.  So, for
example, when you take your
device, the activity gets
destroyed and then re-created.
So to help with this, we
introduced a lifecycle and the
lifecycle owner.  So an activity
or a fragment has a life cycle.
Therefore, they are autolife
cycle owner.  And the life cycle
of a
lifecycleownerring with can be
observed by a
lifepsycherobserver.  In that
observer, we can define methods
that will be called whenever
life cycle events are triggered.
All you need to do is annotate
with lifecycle.event, plus the
event name that you're
interested in.  Architecture
components provides one such
component, which is live data.
Live data is a data holder.  So
it can hold information about
the user, for example.  And
other components can set the
value that is being called.
And activities and fragments
with so objects that have a life
cycle can observe that live
data.  And then they can react
on the changes of that live
data.  And then they can update
the UI, for example.  But when
the activities are destroyed,
the subscriber is removed.  So
the live data is considered
enactive, and the events are not
propagated.  But once the
activity is re-created, we
subscribe again and we can
update the UI.
The Cloud is designed to store
and manage the  UI data that
survives configuration changes,
it's the ViewModel.  So let's
see how the life cycle of the
ViewModel look like compared to
the activity life cycle.  We can
see that we can create a
ViewModel only once the activity
is created.  And then the
ViewModel will only be destroyed
from the activity is finished.
So more precisely, the
ViewModel survives configuration
changes, but it will not
survive pressing back on your
phone,  killing the application
from recess, or when the
fragment kills your application.
So this means that the
ViewModel is perfect for
handling long-running
operations.  Because the
ViewModel will be updated
independent on whether the data
is observed or not.
So this means that you will no
longer get these null pointer
exceptions when trying to update
a nonexistent view.  So make
sure you avoid  referencing
Views in ViewModels because they
can lead to memory leaks or
crashes.
So the mind-set here changes a
little bit because instead of
pushing the data to the UI, you
let the UI observe the changes.
So just make sure you don't
hold any UI logic in the view,
but rather move this in the
ViewModel so it can be easily
unit tested.  So, for example,
it will be the ViewModel's
responsibility to get the user,
prepare it to be displayed, and
hold it for the UI.  And then
the UI will notify the ViewModel
of the user's actions.
The ViewModel would work with a
repository.  This will be a
class that you define.  To get
and set the data.  So the
repository models are -- modules
-- are responsible for handling
data operations.  They provide
clean API to the rest of the
application.  They know where to
get the data, what the API  is
called to make when the data is
updated.  So you can see them as
mediators between different
data sources.  So it's a good
idea to have a data point in
your app completely unaware of
the presentation layer.  Because
algorithms that synchronize or
keep caches or make database
synchronizations are quite
complicated.  So you want to add
a single point of entry to your
data.
So this means that the
repository will know which API
to call to get the user from the
network.  And because you want
to make sure that we don't
request the data too many times,
we also want to save it locally
in the database.  But to save
the data in the database
, architecture components comes
with a new one -- room.  It's an
object mapping library that
provides data assistance with
minimum boiler code.  So, for
example, let's say this is our
user's table that has a user ID,
which is a primary ID and a
name and all sorts of other
information about the user.
And what we want is actually
every instance of that -- of the
row should be an instance of a
user object.  So to do this, we
define a user data model that we
just annotate with entity.
Here we define the primary key
and the column influence.  To
actually access the data in the
database, we work with DAOs.
Data access objects.  We use DAO
and define access points,
queries, inserts, updates and
deletes.  Queries can also
return live data objects.  So
they're making this query an
observable query.  So what's an
observable query?  Let's say we
have this user's table and we
want to get the users by  ID.
So let's say that we're
interested in the user with ID 4
.  So live data will get the
initial data from the database,
which is the user with the name,
John.  But then, when we update
the data in the table with --
let's say -- Mark, instead of
John -- the live data will
automatically fit that new
information.  So using
observable queries means that we
have a UI that observes -- that
reflects the latest changes in
the databases.  Because the
repository would expose a live
data object.  And then the
ViewModel will also expose a
live data object for the UI.  So
what I have been mentioning
before until now was the
ViewModels and with the
repositories is what we call a
guide to app architecture.
It provides testability and
separations of concerns.  When I
saw the questions about this.
So, for example, how many
LiveData objects should I expose
from my ViewModel?  Should I
have -- let's say that the
LiveData contains the model for
the screen.  Should I expose
only one?  Should I expose
multiple?  So let's say that the
top part contains some user
information, and then the bottom
part, some general settings
data.  So you can see that
actually these are two different
logical units.
So what you could do is group
together these logical units so
you could expose a LiveData from
the user info, and then another
LiveData for the  settings.
What if I'm using a MVP?  Should
I switch to MVVM?  Should
you replace with the ViewModel?
It depends.  How much logic
you have on how testable your
classes are.  The main idea is
you should keep the logic in
activities and in fragments to a
minimum.  What you could do is
put a ViewModel between the
presenter and the repository and
still let the presenter work
with the view.  But what's
extremely important is not to
let ViewModels and the
presenters know about the end
framework classes.  And make
sure you distribute
responsibilities.  Don't be
afraid to create new classes.
Should I use LiveData if I'm
already using RX Java?  If
you're already using RX Java,
your project looks
is something like this.  You're
using it on the database part,
the network part.  You have a
repository that exposes
observables and ViewModels that
also do that.  So one way you
could do this is split the
responsibility.  LiveData was
made for the UI.  So you could
leverage that and let the
LiveData handle the connection
between the ViewModel and your
activities or fragments.  You
could use a composite disposal
where you keep your positions to
the RX Java.  And then in the
ViewModel all clear, you just
clear those disposables.  How
about the data?  How do we save
it?  Where do we save it?
Should you save it in the
database?  In the ViewModel?
What should you save on save
instance?  So before going over
the few scenarios, let's look at
this again.
So only when the activity is
finished, only then the
ViewModel is cleared.  So let's
remember this.  So let's see
what happens when the
application starts.  When the
activity starts, you call
OnCreate.  And then the
ViewModel.  It will talk to the
repository to get the user.  So
the repository will do a request
to the network calling a get
user from your backend.  The
repository will save that user
information in the database.
And then it will expose that
information to the ViewModel.
The ViewModel will create the
model for the UI because maybe
you don't want to enclose all of
that information that you have
about your user.  Maybe on the
first one and the last one.  And
then the activity will use that
information and will display
it.  Let's see what happens when
you do configuration changes.
So, for example, when we are
rotating the device.  So on
configuration change, the OnStop
is being called.  But the
ViewModel still exists, still
holds a reference to the UI
model.  When the application
goes to foreground, it's
re-created, the OnStart is
created.  And we get the reasons
from the ViewModel.  That's it.
We don't need to work with the
repository at all.  Let's say
that our application goes to
background and then the user
navigates back to the app.
So in this case, when the
activity goes to background,
OnSaveed instancestate is
called.  And when then when the
activity goes to foreground, we
display the user information
based on whatever we have in the
ViewModel.  Again, without
requesting anything from the
network.  So now we are on
three.  Application goes to
background.  And then the
process is killed.  So in this
case, when the data goes to
background, we should OnSaveed
Instance state, we should save
the user ID.  This is why --
because when the process is
killed, the ViewModel is also
killed.  So when the activity
starts in the  OnCreate, we have
it in the user ID.  We can
inform the ViewModel about the
user ID we're interested in and
the ViewModel will talk to the
repository to get the user.  But
the repository already has that
information in the database, so
we no longer need to do another
network request just to get the
user.
So the
OnSaveinstance state allows us
to have the information to
restore the UI without network
requests.  So what should you
put in each of them?  In the
database, put the data that
survives process death.  In the
ViewModel, put the data that's
needed by the UI.  And then in
onSavedinstancestate, put the
minimum information needed to
restore the data.  Instead of
just the user, let's consider
that we have a list of users.
Many applications need to load a
lot of information from the
database.  Database queries can
take a long time to run and use
a lot of memory.  And we have a
new paging library that we will
release soon that can help you
with all of this.  So the main
components of the paging library
are, the  PagedList adapters
that extends the adapter, a list
and a data source.  The
datasource is an interface for
the sources to provide
information gradually.  But
you'll need to implement one of
the two  datasources.  Either a
keyed datasource when you need
to load based on the item and
minus one, or a tiled datasource
which allows you to jump in any
state of your data set
instantly.  And you also need to
implement another method,
loadcount.  This will be the one
that tells whether you have an
infinite or a finite amount of
items that you need to display
in your list.
The pagedlist is a component
that loads the data
automatically and can provide
update signals, for example, to
the adapt.  The data is loaded
automatically from a data source
on the background thread, but
then it's consumed on the main
thread.  And it supports both an
infinite scrolling list, but
also countable lists.  And you
can configure several things.
You can configure the initial
load size, the page size, but
also the prefetch distance.
So here's the data flow.  Let's
say that we have some data that
we put on the datasource on the
background thread.  The
datasource invalidates the page
list and updates its value.  And
then, on the main thread, the
pagelist notifies the otherrers
of the new value.  Now the page
knows about the new  one.  On
the background thread, the
pagelistadapter needs to compute
what changed?  What's the
difference?  And then back on
the UI thread, the view is
updieted in the onBind
viewholder.  This happens
automatically.  You just insert
an item in the database and see
it animated in, and no UI code
is required.
Okay.  Let's look at the code a
bit.  So to tell the adapter how
to compute between the two
elements, you need a new class.
Diff callback.  You will define
two things, to compute whether
the contents are the same, and
how to define whether the items
are the same.  Simplify the
connection between the
datasource and the recyclerview,
we can use the
livepaged listprovider.  This
will expose live data of a paged
list of our user.  So all you
will need to do is provide a
datasource.  But if that
datasource is true, then it will
be generated for you.  You
don't need to write any
invalidating handling code.  You
can simply bind the livedata to
the page list and get updates
and validates and life cycle
cleanup with a single line of
binding code.
So in our user DAO, we would
return a live page list provider
of our users to get the users
by the last name.  And then, in
the ViewModel, we would extend
from the architectural component
ViewModel, and then keep the
live page list.  And we will get
that reference from the DAO by
calling get users by the last
name.  And then calling create,
using the configuration that you
want.  So, for example,
setting the page size to 50,
setting the prefetch distance to
50 and so on.
In our activity, the activity
needs to be, of course, a
lifecycleowner.  And then in the
onCreate, we get to reference
our ViewModel.  We get a
reference to the recyclerview,
and we create our adapter.  And
then we use another handy class
from the architecture
components.
LivelistadapterUtil.  This
provides hooks for live data and
life cycle so you can bind with
just one line of code and not
worry about the cleanup.
And then we are just setting the
adapter to the recyclerview.
Let's look at the adapter.  So
our adapter will extend page
list adapter and then connect
the user, the information they
need to supply, with the user.
And then we define the
callback, the diff callback for
our user objects.  And then in
onBind
viewholder, we bind the item to
the view.  That's all.  We have
a lot of new  concepts and
components with architecture
components, but the thing is,
you can use them separately.  So
if you want, you only will be
able to use lifecycle, livedata
or pagelist.  Or only ViewModel.
But you can also use them
together.  So start using the
architecture components to
create a more testable
architecture for your
application.  Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Hello. Hello. It's great to
see so many of you here.  My
name is Mete Atamel.  I'm at
Google based in London.
[ Applause ]
>> [speaking many another
language]
>> I don't know what you said,
but I hope it was good.
>> I'm not sure either, but I
think I said, good morning, and
welcome you to our session.
>> Great. First of all, before
we start the talk, you might be
wondering, what's a developer
advocate?  One of my good
friends basically said a
developer advocate is a software
engineer who has license to
speak.  I think that kind of
captures what we do.  We are
software engineers by
experience.  But we come to
events like this and talk about
Google Cloud-related
technologies.  At the same time
we want to get your feedback, so
-- and bring that back to
engineering.  So after this talk
we have office hours on level
three.  So if you have questions
or feedback about Google Cloud,
come and see us.  Today we want
to talk about the fundamentals
of the Google Cloud Platform.
We have a Bitly link for the
slides, if you want the slides,
get it there.  I have been with
Google for one and a half years.
But Marc has been around more
than me.  Since 2011.  Marc, you
want to tell us about the good
old days in 2011?  How it was?
>> Sure. So back when I started
, Google Cloud Platform was
quite a bit simpler.  This is
actually what the platform
Website looked like in 2012.
There were four products, Appear
Engine, compute engine, Cloud
storage and big query.  You
could get your head around the
entire product offering.  Those
were the good old days for me.
This is what it's like nowadays.
We have more than 60 Google
Cloud product services and so
many that I can't even fit them
all on one slide.  So there's a
lot of choices out there.
>> That's good, right? Marc?
More tools, more choice, that
can be only good, right?
>> It's a mixed bag, actually.
The good news is we have tons of
capables.  You can build almost
anything you can imagine now.
It's a powerful platform.  But
there's a high cognitive load.
You have to think and understand
a little bit more to understand
what tool to use, when to use
it and how to use it.  Greg
Wilson came up with this chart,
which I think is really nice as
a reference.  And by the way,
for anybody photographing, we
have the slides online right
now.  Feel free to photograph,
but we'll share this with you.
It's actually up  now.  But this
chart summarizes every Cloud
product -- every Google Cloud
product in four words or less.
So it's a really nice synopsis.
Today we're going to focus on
the four highlighted areas.  And
even there we're not going to
get to go too  deeply because we
have 30 minutes to cover all of
this stuff.  And each of the
products, we could spend hours
on.  But we'll focus on those
four  areas.  We'll probably
touch on
a few others.  And we'll try to
just give you a high-level view,
essentially a roadmap, of all
the capabilities of
Google Cloud Platform.
>> First, let's talk about
compute.  I heard in the keynote
there was a compute section.
Hopefully new stuff.  And you
have code and want to run on
Google Cloud, what options do
you have?  That's what we're
trying to answer.  At the high
level, you have three separate
buckets when it comes to how to
deploy your code.   The first
one is virtual  machines.  You
can think of these as physical
machines, except their
virtualized and running in
someone else's data center.  You
can pick and choose the CPU,
the memory you want.  And the
operating system, Linux or
Windows-based.  And once you
have the machine, you can
install whatever you want so you
have full control, but at the
same time you have full
responsibility with virtual
machines.  So virtual machines
are great, but kind of heavy
weight because you need to
virtualize the whole operating
system and everything on top of
that.  So more recently,
something called containers.  So
the idea with containers,
instead of virtualizing
the  operating system, you're
running the process that runs.
You're virtualizing the
application and its
dependencies.  And from there,
you create a  container image.
And this container image is much
more lightweight than virtual
machines.  So  containers are
really easy to move around.
They're really fast to start.
They're much quicker and agile
way of running your
applications.
And if you're like me, you
usually don't care about
infrastructure.  You don't want
to care about virtual machineses
or containers, you want to
deploy your code and let someone
else manage it for you, that's
when serverless comes in.  In
serverless, create a function,
deploy it, and let someone else
scale it for you, run it for
you.  All that kind of stuff.
>> So as Matt just said,
containers have really changed
everything.  That's another
thing I have noticed over the
last five years has had a huge
impact on the entire industry
and the cloud in particular.  It
kind of really picked up steam
when Docker was released in 2013
.  So containers really enable a
bunch of things that we didn't
have before.  But containers by
themselves are not enough.  If
you think about deploying your
applications in  containers,
these entirely self-contained
modular units that you can kind
of scale incrementally, it's
wonderful.  But if you have a
complex application with a bunch
of frontend servers, a bunch of
backend servers, maybe some
middleware.  It's difficult to
get it to work together, to
monitor it and restart when they
fail.  That's where
orchestraters come in.  The most
popular is Kubernetes.  And
another piece you kind of have
to reinvent if somebody hasn't
created a nice pattern for you
to reuse is the service access
layer.  So if you
want to apply some security
policies, telemetry, capture
analytics.  Customize how your
service is accessed, it's really
nice to have a server layer on
top of it.  And that's what
Istio is as a service mesh.  The
combination of all these
together: containers,
orchestraters and a service mesh
give you a way to manage and
deploy your apps, especially in
the  Cloud.
>> Yep. Let's look at what you
have on Google Cloud as products
to deploy your applications.
The first thing that you want to
decide is how much
customization you want and how
much management you want.  So
there's a spectrum.  The more
highly managed things are, the
less customizable.  And if you
want them customized, you have
to maintain it yourself.  So if
you want to have things
customizable, you have compute
engine.  So the idea of the
Compute Engine, you heard in the
keynote, a  VM and the memory
you choose.  Once you have the
VM, it's yours and you can do
whatever you want with it.  You
get the machine and the
operating system with  it.
At some point you might want to
put some software on it.  One
way of doing that is you can
install that yourself manually,
but we also have something
called Cloud Launcher.  It's
kind you have like a marketplace
for solutions to apply to
Google Cloud.  So you can
install things like Mongo DB,
framework, and there's a bunch
of other solutions from Google
and from outside Google.  So the
ideas of Cloud Launcher is that
with one click, you can get a
solution for the Compute Engine.
So let me show you some of
this quickly.  Here I am nor
Google Cloud Console.  You have
probably seen this before.  We
have a bunch of products on
Google Cloud.  But the one we
are interested in is the Compute
Engine.  And I can see the VMs.
And these are the VMs I have
running.  If I want to create a
VM, create instance and this
takes me to a new page.  I'll
give my instance a name.  So
let's call this instance
GDDkrakow.  And then you can
choose a zone.  So we have zones
all over the world, but
since we're in Europe, let's
choose west.  So for machine
type, you can customize it, you
can pick and choose how many
cores you want and how much
memory you want from one CPU to
64 CPU.  And you can choose
preconfigured instances.  I'm
going to choose M1 standard with
one CPU and 4 gigs of memory.
And then choose the operating
system.  Linux, containerized
optimized system.  And even
Windows servers -- 2008, 12, 16.
If you want the SQL server,
you can install that.  Choose
autoLinux instance and standard.
And then you can allow HTTPS
and create.  And this will give
you a VM within a few seconds.
So I have analytics running.
You can easily access that.
Just click this button and you
don't have to worry about keys
and everything is fully managed.
So this will launch within a
few seconds and you can get into
it and do all that stuff.  But
if you're a Windows person, I
have a Windows app running here.
You can add VP into that.  And
right from the browser, and
just enter my
password.  And then -- boom.
You're in and you can do all the
Windows stuff that you need to
do.
So that's how you get VMs.  But
if you want to install something
on these VMs, then there's
Cloud Launcher.  So go here.
Cloud Launcher.  This is -- as I
mentioned before, a marketplace
for different solutions.  You
can install WordPress with one
click.  I'll search for asp.net.
I want to install the asp.net
framework.  So this solution
give use a Windows server, and
SQL express.  So just launch
compute engine, and give a name,
choose my zone as west again.
I'll keep my machine type as it
is, and Windows server, choose
the latest one and keep the
default.  Keep deploy.  This
will give me a Windows server
with IIS and SQL server express
deployed.  It will take a couple
minutes, but it's right there.
So that's that, but as we
mentioned, virtual machines are
kind of old school now, so we
have containers.  And how you
run containers on Google Cloud?
The easiest way to do that is
with App  Engine.  Take the code
and deploy it using G Cloud.
And take the code and create a
container and host it on
container repository and deploy
to App Engine.  So with App
Engine you get dashboards by
default.  You get versions.
Every time you have the
application, you get different
versions.  You get traffic
splitting.  So you have multiple
versions, you can split them.
And scaling.  And you can scale
all the way to 20.  It's the
easiest way to start with
containers on Google Cloud.  But
at some point you might need
more control.
Sometimes you want to be able to
define multiple containers and
you want to be able to scale
them independently.  So you
basically want to create a
container cluster.  For that we
have container engine.  So
container engine is basically
managed Kubernetes.  We manage
Kubernetes for you.  And with
one command, you can get a
Kubernetes class and a master
and nodes and you can use the
SQL command line tool to
schedule containers.  And we
have tools around containers.
So we have container building
which is a way to build
containers in the cloud really
fast.  And then we have
container registry.  So once you
build the containers, they get
hosted into a private space for
the project.  And once you have
the image, you can deploy to App
Engine or you can deploy to
Container Engine.  Anything you
want.  It's available to
everything that you have.
And then finally, my favorite is
Cloud  Functions.  So in Cloud
Functions, you create a function
that does some functionality
and define what triggers the
function.  It gets triggered by
calls, or by messages, and then
you just deploy that and don't
worry about containers or VMs.
Everything is fully managed for
you.  Take a quick look at these
as well.
So I already deployed an App
Engine  application.  So I'll
take a look at that.  So go to
App Engine.  First I will click
on versions and then you can see
that I have two versions
already  deployed.  Let's say
this version 3 is the one
getting the traffic and it's
being run on two instances.
Version 4 is not getting any
traffic.  I can easily change
that so I can come here, reduce
traffic.  I will do IP-based
traffic splitting.  I'll add my
version and let's say this got
50%.  So now each version will
get 50% of the traffic so I can
do my testing and make sure
everything works.  So if we go
back here, they are both getting
50% of the traffic.  If I go to
dashboard, this app is not
being used, you don't see much.
Under here you see the
different versions and click on
the version.  And you can see
the latency, traffic, VM
traffic.  All this stuff comes
for free.  You can see the
instances.  So by default the
apps run on two instances and
these are regular VMs.
You can add App Engine if you
want, but it measures for you
and this will be auto-scaled
from two to 20 if there's a need
.  So that's kind of App Engine.
And then if you look at
Container Engine, I can take the
same container image and upload
into Container Engine and
manage by Kubernetes.  Here I
have a cluster already defined.
And look under workloads, you
basically take your container
and put it in what's called a
pod.  So I have a pod running
with the same app.  And once you
have the pod, you can expose
that to the outside world using
something called service.  With
service you get a load balancer
and a public  IP.  If I click on
this, I have hello world.
Exciting application.  And you
can take the same app and move
it around from App Engine to
Container Engine easily.  What I
really like is Cloud
Functions.  It's a hello world
cloud function.  And if you
click on it, it's running in the
cloud.  I don't know or care
anyway.  I can see the
trigger.  This is a triggered
function, meaning if there's a
topic, and a message that goes
to the topic, it will be
triggered.  I can even see the
source of it.  Here is my
function and basically gets an
event and displayed the message.
And you can test from here.
In here, I can send the message,
let's say this is message.  And
then I'll say, "Hello world."
And test the function and this
will invoke my function.  And
when it's done, I can see the
output, everything right here.
It's really easy and a fully
managed product.
So go back.
>> So, thanks. I'd like to
briefly touch on something that
I think is largely invisible to
most people when they're using
our Cloud Platform.  When you
deploy one of the computing
elements that Mete just talked
about, the data moving around
either from the outside world
into Google's Cloud or between
systems into our Cloud is riding
on top of the same network that
powers the seven products.
Each with a billion users.  So
we don't have like a separate
network where we're transporting
all the information for your
cloud, you know, compute
elements and another network
that we make good for our
internal use.  It's the same
network fabric.  Extremely high
performance.  And, you know,
it's the same network that's
serving up all those YouTube
videos, to Gmail, Google Search,
Maps, et cetera.  And the
reason it's so high-performance
is that Google has built its own
private network.  Massive
internal private network.  It
contains dedicated fiber links
around the world.  We
even own our
own undersea cables.
And as a result, I mean, it's
not just the facilities.  A ton
of
engineering work has made it be
high performance and low
latency and you're  taking
advantage of all that power when
you're  running your
applications in our cloud.
Another kind of key design piece
of our network is that we built
it so that when users want to
access our cloud platform, App
Engine apps or Compute Engine or
containers or any of that
stuff, we have it designed so
that we route their connections
to the closest point of presence
to that user.  The idea being
that we want to get them on this
high-speed Google backbone as
fast as possible so that the
bulk of the communication is
taking place over this very
optimized network.  And as a
result, we not only get a very
high throughput and low latency,
but we get very predictable
response time.  And this is a
little map of the extension of
our data centers around the
world.  As you can see, we're in
a lot of areas, but we're
constantly trying to expand
the footprint to accommodate
platform needs all around the
world.  We also have several
higher end  networking
capabilities which I'm not going
into today.  But we will have
resources at the end so you can
dive into those if you're
interested.
So we've talked about computing
and talked a little bit about
networking.  And now I want to
turn to how you store your data.
Something everybody has to --
everybody application has to do.
And I'm going to try to cover
everything you can do in that
domain in one slide.  So it's
going to get a little bit busy.
We have several products.  It's
really like tools in a tool
kit.  And it just -- some really
powerful options, but it's just
a matter of knowing what to use
for what situation.  The first
is in memory storage.  This is
caching for your app.  Think of
Redis or mem cache, those
services.  And then the
traditional SQL-based databases.
And Cloud SQL, think of
managed MySQL or postgres.  It's
backed up, but you're thinking
about database servers at the
end of the day.  And then
Spanner which takes it up a
level which you can think about
just the database independent of
the service.  It's database as
a service with a lot of other
nice features as well.  And then
on the no
SQL side, Cloud Datastore, a
hierarchical store that comes
out of the App Engine world but
now is generalized and can be
used anywhere.  And Cloud
Bigtable similarly schema less
and no SQL.  Suited for
high-capacity storage jobs and
for very high-volume read and
write scenarios like an event
log or page views and, you know,
detailed telemetry
applications.
We have an object store called
Google Cloud  Storage.  This is
one of the very first products
that came out as part of the
Google Cloud Platform.  It was
the first product I work on back
in 2011.  It's a very powerful
binary object storage facility.
Global scope, replication, and
strong consistency.  Very nice
features.  And then we have
block storage device.  We call
these persistent disk.  This is
a network device for attaching
you to your VMs.  And the idea
is it's network resident and
lives on its own life cycle.  So
if your VM goes down, or you
delete the VM, your data is
still persistent on that disk.
And you can get those in SSD
format or  spinning disks.  Lots
more to say about that, but I'm
trying -- for time -- get
through it.  And, of course, Big
Query which we'll see more.
That's a good way to store data
as well as analyze it
interactively.
>> That's a lot of options. But
Spanner -- can you tell us
what's special about Spanner?
>> Funny you should ask. I
actually have a slide about
Spanner, Mete, thank you.  And
it would have been good if I
didn't advance to it early.   So
-- yeah.  Cloud
Spanner is very new.  It was
announced earlier this year.
It's a really interesting new
database type.  It's basically a
managed, unlimited scaling
effectively database as a
service in the cloud.  Now,
whereas traditional relational
databases are very strong in
terms of asset compliance and
strong consistency and data
semantics, but they are often
difficult to scale.  A lot of
times you'll see companies
having to shard multiple
concurrent instances of an
ArcVMS.  Traditional no SQL is
the inverse of that.  Scales
easily.  You add additional
nodes to a cluster.  But you
often have consistency
challenges trying to make sure
everything is strongly
consistent and updates are seen
at the same time.  Spanner gives
you the best of both worlds.
The scalability of a no-SQL
system and gives you the
semantics of a traditional
relationship database management
.
And I would like to actually
show you real quick what it
looks like to work with Spanner.
So this is the same platform
-- or same console,  rather,
that Mete was just showing you.
But I'm in the Spanner domain.
We create instances.  Instances
are simply collections of
databases.  But they're
completely abstract.  I don't
have to think about how the
software is configured or
anything like  that.  Within the
instance, I create a database.
So I'm going to take this sort
of imagery example that a
university administer -- and I
need to keep track of the data
for all the students in the
university.  So I've created a
database I call University.  And
I have two tables in that
database -- departments -- so
these are the different subjects
areas.  They have a department
ID and a budget and a name.  And
students.  So these are an
enumeration of all the students.
So I have a department ID,
which is inherited.  So every
student affiliated with a
department.  And
an SID, the student ID, you need
key for this table.  And a
student name.  Now, one of the
nice things about Spanner, I can
dynamically change the schema.
Let's say I want to add a
column to this table.  So I'll
say edit schema.  Anybody have
something they would like to add
to the student record?  What's
the -- what's the attribute that
causes college students the
most stress?
>> GPA.
>> Let's add a GPA column.
Let's make it a float.  Add that
and say save.  It's now
updating the schema.  There can
be tons of data there.  It's
going to update all the data we
have now as well as make it
possible for me to store new
data.  And the database is
continuing to run.  There's no
down  time.  So it's not
stopping ongoing operations.
It's continuing to request as we
speak.  And while it's doing
that schema upgrade, I'm going
to show you another thing.
Let's say I'm wildly successful
with my new database and I have
more load than I can possibly
take.  And I just told you
earlier that it's really
scalable.  So what I can do is
go to the instance page.  Maybe.
There we go.  And I can say,
edit instance.  And I can simply
change the number of nodes from
one to three.
Save.  And I now have tripled my
capacity that easily.  I now
have three times as much as
database capacity as I did
before.  That's -- I think the
schema update is done.  You can
see.  And being able to turn
that knob is really one of the
major advantages of Spanner's
scalability.  All right?
>> So now let's talk about big
data in the last four minutes
that we have.  So big data at
Google started with MapReduce.
Back in the day we were  trying
to preserve data.  And there was
a paper on
MapReduce that explained how to
take lots of data and break it
into small chunks and map them
to different machines and apply
an aggregation and get a result
back.  After MapReduce, there
was a lot of innovation at
Google.  These were either
papers or internal
implementations that people
couldn't use outside of Google.
We have papers, we have things
like Spark and Hive.  And
because of the split in
innovation, we have two products
on Google Cloud.  We have
Dataflow, basic the way the
state of the art pipeline that
came up at Google and now we are
making available to people.
But at the same time, if you are
using Hadoop
and Spark, there's Cloud
Dataproc.  It's a way to run
jobs on Google Cloud.
>> So if we think about the big
data world, the typical thing we
want to do is have a processing
pipeline.  So I'm just going to
briefly walk through that
pipeline.  The first phase would
be capturing your data.  And
we'll come up with an example of
how you might do this.  Imagine
you wanted to track all the
activity on Wikipedia.  You had
an event firing, HTTP post or
something.  And any time they
pulled up the PDF, Cloud Pub/Sub
is a high-capacity repository
and it's a message queue and can
publish the events to any
number of downstream consumers.
We might feed that downstream
into dataprep, a way to cleanse
your data and add semantic
checking and add things.  And
that might speed too dataflow, a
very flexible pipeline building
tool.  You can use Apache
Beam there.  And it can go on
large batches of data or
streaming data so you could use
it in sort of a  real-time
fashion.
The output of that would be the
process data.  We want to store
in one of the storage facilities
I mentioned earlier.  We could
do real-time analysis on it
using big query, I'll show you
an example of that in a second.
And might want to take it and
work on it interactively in a
user friendly way.  And we have
the ability to use Jupiter
notebooks to play with the data,
and Data Studio, a nice tool
for building interactive
dashboards and other
visualizations.
So let's hop over to the console
again.  This is a different
part of the console.  But this
is for running Big Query.  And I
have preloaded a month's worth
of Wikipedia page views into
this particular database.  Here
is my query.  I can format it
nicely.  I'm going to turn off
use cached results.  I don't
want to cheat.  It will come
back blindingly fast, but won't
be true.  I want to run this
query.  What this is doing is
scanning every line in the
database and looking for
occurrences of "Krakow."
Because the O can be written in
different ways, depending on
language, I've used a regular
expression to avoid that.
So not only am I scanning every
row in the table, I'm running a
regular expression on every
single row in this table.  I got
any output.  And if we look at
the job information, we see that
it's scanned almost 50
gigabytes of data.  And the
query explanation shows the
number of rows.  It scanned  1.8
billion -- with a B -- didn't
just scan them  all, ran a
regular expression on them.  I
didn't mention the punchline, it
was under 5 seconds.  In under
5 seconds, we ran regular
expression queries on 1.8
billion rows.  Hopefully that
gives you an idea of the speed
you'll get with big query.
>> And last, but not least,
machine learning.  Machine
learning is big and this graph
shows why.  This is the model
initial learning at Google and
all the different products that
use machine learning.  You can
see exponential growth in the
last few  years.  When it comes
to using machine learning in
your applications, you have two
ways of using machine learning.
The easy way is to let someone
build a new model and give you
an API and use that machine
learning for your application.
So you're not really building
machine learning yourself,
you're consuming someone else
's machine learning model.  And
sometimes the model is not good
enough or you need to customize
things.  You need to create your
own machine model.  You can
create and serve your own
machine model.  So in terms of
using models at Google Cloud, we
have machine learning APIs for
the different models over the
years.  Speech API for speech,
and vision API for vision
recognition.  We have built
these over the years and we're
making it available to you with
an API call.  I want to show a
quick demo on an API.  So in
vision API, you pass an image
and then you get information
about the image using machine
learning.  Here I have a picture
of a cute cat.  Sorry for the
dog lovers, I don't have a dog
picture.  But in this one, I
pass this image to vision API
and then I get a JSON back.
Look at the JSON in a graphical
way, the machine figured out
this is a cat.  And even figured
out this is a British
short-haired cat.  From there,
you can extract the color,
whether it's an adult or medical
image.  If you pass in more
complicated things, like a
stadium, it figures out it's a
baseball stadium.  It picks up
the text from different places.
It even picks up people's
expressions.  It picked up this
guy and the fact that he is
joyful.  And even knows the
location.  You can see the kinds
of things you can get from
vision API.
>> Thanks. So underlying all of
those products that you saw,
that exponential curve that Mete
just showed, is TensorFlow.
And for those who have
encountered it, it's a framework
for building machine learning
models that Google open sourced
almost two years ago.  It's
become a communal open source
project.  Tremendous
contributions and tremendous
popularity.  It's particularly
well-suited for building complex
deep learning  models and
neural networks and those sorts
of  things.  And when you start
to get into that domain, you
really need power.  You need
computational  power.  It's not
one of those models you can just
run on the laptop or something.
And that's where Cloud Machine
Learning Engine comes in.  We
have built this product to make
it really easy to build and
serve models -- TensorFlow
models -- in the cloud.  So the
idea here is you get a fully-
managed infrastructure.  You
build your model prototype,
perhaps on your
workstation or wherever.  And
then you upload it to the cloud
and you'll benefit from very
optimized environment for
training and for serving your
requests.
The other advantage you get is
the TensorFlow processing unit,
which is optimized hardware we
have built ourselves, custom
ASICs that do the Tensor math
faster than we have been able to
do in the  past.  The result of
all this is that we're making
it easier for people to build a
complex model so that you can
really focus on the model and
not worry about things like,
where do I run it?  How do
gigabytes of the CPUs I need?
How do I get the  GP   Us?
Coordinate parallel processing
?  You can focus on your own
model.
>> That's it. That's a lot of
information.   The main page is
cloud.google.com.  But there's
other links as well.  We have a
free trial if you want to try it
out, it's
cloud.google.com/free.  You get
to try for free.  See what you
like and don't like.
>> That's the best way to learn.
We're trying to tell you what
it's all about.  But learn but
doing is a great way to go.
Avail yourself of the three
tier.  Try some things out, try
building something.  We think
you'll have a lot of fun.  And
maybe you'll build the next
amazing application.  And with
that -- thank you very much.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
This is a captioning test.
Testing testing testing, this is
a captioning test.
testing.
FOERFS
Thank you for joining us for
this exciting talk about
Kubernetes and the Container
Cloud.  We will talk about how
to deploy Kubernetes at FlixBus.
I'm also a Google Cloud
developer, so we understand
ourselves as software developers
with a license to speak, or a
way that I like to introduce
myself is the bi-directional
interface between you guys, who
develop
on our platform and the
software engineers at Google
that develop the products.  So
please reach out to us with good
and bad feedback so we can
improve our products.
Let's go back a little bit in
the history, some of you might
remember
these, I have one of these here,
the flopy disks, and that is
what we used in the '80s and
'90s to install operating
systems and things like Word
Perfect on machines.  And you
basically had your machine and
your programs all on that.
And fast forward, today, it is
not that easy anymore.  We live
in a mobile world and everyone
wants access to everything at
any time, if you develop a
really popular app, you want to
scale the demand based on, like,
if people are waking up, or
throughout the day, or playing
throughout the coffee and lunch
break.  Applications look like
this, you have multiservices,
you need load balancing and
things like that.  We heard
about the storage options we had
in the Google Cloud platform we
had before.
And as a developer, myself, I
don't want to really deal with
operating that, I don't want to
look at, like, is my app still
running, do I have to move my
app from A to B because I do
maintenance, or things like
that.  All I really care about
is adding more features and
innovating and pushing it out to
the users as fast as possible.
So, how can we do that? So if we
look at a little bit of the
history how apps work, and the
apps we are deplaying --
deploying on machines, basically
on hardware, back in the days,
we started with installing the
operating system directly on
your physical machine and adding
all the apps and dependencies
of the apps to this machine.
And now, usually one app might
not have exhausted that machine,
you will add multiple apps to
that machine and they might
interfere.
And you know the term, never
change a running system, that is
from the status.  When you have
it running, you don't want to
touch it.  That hinders
innovation and rolling out new
features.
So, to get a little bit more
isolation between your
applications and to make it a
little bit safer in terms of
iterating to new versions,
there's a new thing that came
out a decade ago, maybe a little
bit more than that, where we
lookeded at, okay, how can we
not disrupt the physical
hardware and run the operating
system in a virtual environment
and have more than one on a
virtual machine? That's where
virtual machines came in.  But
this virtual machine still had
an operating system, you still
had to install patches for
security and things like that.
So this took a while, if you
wanted to iterate, if you wanted
to start up a new version of
your application, it still took,
like, a minute to start up this
operating system, so it took
quite some time if you had to
react to the demands in your
applications.
And now, the new way to do
things is actually to go another
layer above and really
encapsulating all of the things
you really need for the
application and sharing more of
what you had before.  So if you
look more, you had the operating
system and the kernel that you
actually can share, and you have
the container that we package
our application in the
container.  It is pretty much
just running as a process in
your operating system.  And with
this, it is super lightweight
and can be started and stopped
within seconds.
And now, I have all of these
containers, which enable me to
innovate and roll out changes
quickly.  But as I mentioned
before, applications are
complex.  So what I wanted to
do, I want a system that helps
me to run all of these
containers.  And that is where
Kubernetes comes into play.
Kubernetes was inspired by how
we are running containers inside
of Google.  We are running
billions of containers, starting
and stopping them, every week.
containers in Google in a system
that is called bulk.
And we did not want to bore you,
there is technical depth, but
what we wanted to do, out of
what we learned building this,
we wanted to show the things
that we learned to manage
containers, and that is how
Kubernetes first started from
scratch in Google and was
open-sourced two years ago, and
then was one of
the founding --
was the founding project for the
cloud native computing
computation.
And what Kubernetes does, it
handles failures, it manages
your containers, and there's a
couple core prince
principals for us that are
important in running Kubernetes.
we don't want you to force you
to re-write your applications.
Your You want it as easy as
possible to have your
applications and cull in
Kubernetes.  So containerize
them, and once it is
containerize, your containers
don't need to be special, they
can just run by themselves with
the Docker engine.
And the next thing, we didn't
want to couple parts in
Kubernetes.  If you wanted to
change those things, if united
to change the schedule or things
like that, you can go and check
out the Kubernetes repository
in GitHub and just change the
schedule as you like it.
So it is really about being open
and being able to have everyone
who uses this system to modify
it in a way that they want to.
And really, what is really
really important, what I like to
talk about, is that Kubernetes
is about running applications in
a declarative way, versus an
imperative way.  And that means,
you cell Kubernetes how the
landscape should look like, but
you don't tell it how to get
there, Kubernetes will figure it
out by itself.  And with new
versions of Kubernetes, you get
how to make this even more
efficient.
And another important part for
Kubernetes is supportability,
you can run it on any public
Google Cloud, we make it very
easy to get started, and it is
actually my opinion the easiest
way to get started, and you can
also run it on things like this.
And this is the a Raspberry Pi
cluster, I
installed Kubernetes on this,
and then I can pretty much play
live Chaos Monkey on this Pi
cluster.  If you want to learn
Kubernetes, this is a good bay
to start.
And the core concepts to run
KubernetesKubernetes in the
containers are what I want to
touch on in this session.  First
one, I want to focus on, is
pods.  That is a small group of
tightly couples containers, it
moves through the cluster and
gets an IP, you should never
talk to it because a pod can
start and die at any time.
And now, to make sure that there
are always as many pods
available as you declared in
your configuration files, we
have replicas, or deployments.
And it will say, I want to have
5 pods of this kind, and the
replicas will make sure that
there are only five pods of this
time.
And to make it accessible and to
be able to talk to these pods,
you use services.  And service
is pretty much a load balance
over the pods that you have
available.  And it routes the
travel to the  traffic to the
pods that are available.
And the service and the replica
set, they want to know what they
are responsible for.  And that
is where labels come into play,
it is an orthoginal set on top
of this that you can attach to
any API set in Kubernetes and
run on top of this.  So it runs
on a set of labels to know which
pods it is responsible for, or
a service has a set of labels
can matches to see what kind of
pods to route traffic to.
But this is a lot of words, and
I like living on the edge, so I
actually like to show you a
little live demo.
And now, every live demo has to
start with some kind of, like,
what I want to show or run.  So
in this case, I hope that it is
readable, I have a Go App,
actually.  My language of choice
nowadays is go, it is simple
and easy to get started with it,
if you get the hang of it.  And
in this application, I have two
end points that you see down
here, where I have the host name
and the hello endpoint, and I
let this run on port 8000.
And now, you can see the
implementations of the functions
here, and they basically -- I'm
just returning a string, hello
from GDD Europe, and the other,
I'm responding with the host
name and the version of the
application that I'm running.
And now, the first step that I
want to do is, I actually want
to build a container, I want to
build this app and then put it
into a container that I can run
on Kubernetes.  That is where
Docker File comes in, so in
Kubernetes, you can run
different engines, Docker or
Rocket or two of the supportive
ones that are supported.
And now, since Docker is the
most popular one, I'm going to
run a Docker container.  And
what I'm doing here is actually
something that just recently
came into Docker is a
multi-stage build.  Why am I
doing this? Well, if you build
your application, you need a lot
of build tools, you need your,
like, your compiler and the
linker and all the libraries and
things like that, and your
container is really big.  But I
want to have my container as
small as possible.
As you can see, in the first
step that I'm  I'm doing, I have
the build container and I'm
loading the source code in there
and in the run command that you
see there, I'm building my
staticly-linked binary.  And in
the second stop, I'm copying
from the build container the
binary into the L pine
container, version 3.6.  And L
pine, this base image is really
small, like 8MB.  And even if I
had bad WiFi at a conference, I
could still do this demo most of
the time.
So let's go ahead and do this, I
will build the demo here, you
can see that I have it built.
It goes through all the steps
and builds my
applicationapplication.  Now I
have the container built and
where  I have my container tag,
and I need to make it available
for Kubernetes on Google Cloud.
And so first, before I get
started, I will show in the
upper left a little command that
you see there, that's the
command to get started with
Google Container engine on
Google Cloud, clusters GDD, and
then you wait three minutes and
you have the cluster ready.
And now, what I'm going to do
is, I actually want to push this
to my private registry.  So
what I'm going to do here, I'm
going to push it to my private
registry, and since I pushed it
before it should be pretty
quick, and I'm going to go
through there.
And so now I have it pushed on
my prior registry, I will show
you really quick here, this is
my private registry, it shows
you the container that is
pushed, the versions, and you
can athlete them
delete them and other text.
And the first thing that I'm
going to do, I will show you I
have a Kubernetes cluster
running, is that I have three
nodes in my Kubernetes cluster.
And now, I use cube CDL, which
is like the magic CI tool to
interact with Kubernetes to run
my application.
In this case, I use run, I give
it a name, I point to an image
and I point to the port that I
exposed for this application.
And now, when we do this, I want
to actually show you what is
happening here.
And so, on the upper right, you
see actually three kinds of API
objects that are going to show.
And in the very first, you have
the pods that are running, and
now we have the version one of
the demo app running, and the
second is all the services that
I have, and the third is all the
deployments I have.  And what I
don't have now is a way to talk
to my application.  I have to
make that available to the
outside. And that is where
services come into play.
So what I'm going to do, I will
do cube CDL expose, which gives
me the chance to expose my
service -- either inside the
cluster, or to the outside.  And
how do I make it exposable to
the outside? That is where dash
dash type load balance comes in,
and that tells the Google Cloud
platform to make the external
and internal load balancer
available on the application
outside.
So I have the cluster IP and
internal IP, and it takes a
little bit of time.
And now you might want to de-bug
your application.  And now I
will exit into my container, in
this case, I have to of course
use the ID that you see in the
upper right corner on the top.
And I am going to do
an execute dash, and in the
lower, you can see I'm in the
container, you can see what is
running, my app is running, and
you can do --
and say
http//localhost: 8000.
And it says hello, and it works.
And this givs you the
opportunity to debug and see
what is going on inside the
container.
And now what I'm going to do
next, I will see if it is
externally available.  You can
see that I have an external IP
over there on the right side.
So I'm going to copy this
external IP really quick.
I will put it in here, and run
this, and this refreshes every
second.  And now what I want to
do is, with Kubernetes, is it
makes it very easy to actually
do rolling updates.  So you push
a new version of your
application.
And so, what I want to do here
in this case, I say, okay, you
are an awesome crowd, because
the audience is always awesome.
And then I'm going to save this.
And I'm going to go back to my
shell and build this, so I do a
Docker build and, in this case,
I want to have, of course, a new
version.
So let me go back and give you
version two.  I'm going to build
this, and now you can see that
I made a change, it takes a
little bit longer.  So you are
just going to wait for a second
until it is done.  And, once
it's done, I can now push that
to my container registry.  So I
have G Cloud Docker, push, and
now I push version two.  And now
we wait again a little bit,
while we are waiting, with
Google container engine, you
have a lot of things that are
managed by Google that otherwise
you have to manage yourself.
You have outer scaling, you have
the monitoringinate
integrated, and things like
that.
I want to push out the next
version, and before consider do
-- I do this, I want to show
how easy it is to scale an
application.
So say you have Christmas coming
up and you want to scale up
your application.  You scale up
the deployment, and over on the
right, you have the desired one,
and you can see it coming up on
the right, two new containers
and we are live.  You can see
that we are live on the low and
top left, the host name is
changing, but you still have
version 0.1.  And what I want to
do really quick is actually
edit my deployment, and go to my
version 2.
So this is the configuration
file that you see here, I just
changed live in my configuration
file the version, and I'm
crossing fingers that it will
work, and you can see it is
terminating version 0.1, now it
is running version 0.2 and, as
you can see, up there on the
right it did the rolling update
of my application.
(Applause).
So this hopefully gave you a
brief introduction, thank you
very much.
This hopefully gave you a brief
introduction into what
Kubernetes is capable of.  But
what I'm delighted and excited
about to have here is Steffen
from FlixBus who can talk about
how to implement Kubernetes in
production and talk about the
experience of running Kubernetes
in their company and how it
enabled them to innovate and
grow really, really quick.
So, let's welcome Steffen.
(Applause).
>> Thanks, Robert. I'm Steffen,
I'm an engineer at FlixBus and
we will talk about how we use
Kubernetes in production.
So first, who is
Flixbus? 200 of you actually
traveled here by bus, that is
really cool, we're a
long-distance travel bus
company, but we are not a bus
company.  So even though we have
1100 buses on the streets, we
don't actually own any of those
buses.  You can compare it to
the Uber model, we are doing all
the marketing, planning, the
booking engine, but we do not
operate the buses and we do not
employ any of the bus drivers.
So we cooperate with small- to
mid-sized bus operators for
that.  We have pretty good
growth, the first commit was in
2011.
And now, we have around 40
millionmillion passengers this
year, as an estimate.
And this, at the bottom, this is
a graph of the fleck users in
IT.  And when I joined the
company two years ago, we had
150 people there, and now all
together, it is like 200.
And they are not all engineers,
but it is challenging to grow
that fast.
And so, how did we start?
So, we build a big monolith,
made out of PhP and MySQL and
mem cache and the external
services you have and all the
developers are working on this
monolith, this is challenging
because you want to grow the
engineering power, so we cannot
just work on the single
monolith.  So what do you do?
You sake the newest, fancy
solution that is called
self-contained systems, you
split up the teams and the codes
and the code base by business
domains, and each one of the
self Contained Systems might be
multiple microservices that work
together, and that means
splitting the code base into the
messaging base, you need to
handle data migration and have
new team and new
responsibilities, there's a lot
of challenge in doing that.  And
one of the challenges is
infrastructure.
And so, we use a two-person
team, managing our
infrastructure, and this works
pretty fine.  Over the years, we
are pretty stable.
And of course, that is not a
sustainable solution, especially
if we want to grow the number
of applications that we have.
And so, a small and centralized
team, anytime you need to do
something, you walk to the team
and say, can we upgrade to this
version, can you install this
extension, can you do something
else.
And we were running on Bear
Metal and it was hard to do
system upgrades, we were two
versions behind because there
were more important things to
do.  And, of course, at some
point you cannot scale the
system anymore.
So this, there was low velocity
of new applications and
services.  You need to change it
if you want to do
microservices.
And the goals, in picking a new
infrastructure, in looking for a
solution there, we are a few
goals here.  And it was to be
reproducible and unified
environment for applications
including development.  We have
a lot of boxes, people moving
around, and they are not up to
date with the staging
environment and the production
environment and it is hard to
keep in sync, and containers are
a good fit so they are the same
version and all consistent.
And all teams must iterate their
environment quickly and
independently.  This is really
important, so teams can -- if
one team wants to build PhP5,
and the other PhP7, it is no
problem.  And we want it to be
future proof, we don't want to
re-do everything every two year
years, and what is also really
important is independence.
So Kubernetes is a really great
fit here, and I can talk about a
lot of great stuff in
Kubernetes, for example, pods.
They are a really great way to
model entities in a cluster, and
robust access control is
another great feature to use
overhead.
The deployments are really
amazing in Kubernetes, the
authentication model is really
good, and also the strong API in
the ecosystem in the community
makes Kubernetes special.
And so, let's talk about how you
can use the API to build beyond
grade applications.
So in February 2016, we were
dabbing around with Kubernetes
and there was no Ingress
control, that is a way how to
specify the crowd into your
cluster.
And it was around 200 lines of
Go code, now 100 lines.  And we
wanted to get rid of it, but it
is hard to get rid of temporary
solutions.  This is what the
code looks like, we connect in
Vertigo, to the end point and
say, hey, what is true?
So please give me all the
updates, every time an end point
changes, please give me the new
end points.
And we do some more -- we open
the reader for it.  And when you
connect to this end point, you
get a JSON object per line.  So
we read up to a new line, we
de-code the JSON object, we put
it through a templating engine,
we put it to a directory on the
disk, and you basically
re-load the engine.  And of
course, that's not all the error
handling that is missing there,
but this is still running
production for us.  And it
basically took an afternoon to
write.
And another great part is the
community of
Kubernetes.
So we wanted to run the
integration part of Kubernetes
with the open-ended connect.
And so we submitted a bug, and
we found the corresponding pod
in the Kubernetes source.
And there was a fix in master
seven days later, and six days
later, there was a new release
with the fix included.  So 14
days from reporting to the bug,
to a new release that we can put
into our infrastructure, and
usually you pay a lot of money
for this.  But with Kubernetes,
you get it for free.
And another part, the deployment
in the API.  We tried various
approaches to deploy
applications.  Some developers
use kubectl, some Jenkins, and
some Helm.  But the developers
were saying, is this not working
too well, I think I can do it
better.  And he started doing
it, he created Deployer, which
we are using internally. And the
cool thing about Deployer, it
creates a new staging
environment for every feature
branch.  So in the past, we had
a problem, we would deploy 70
code a day, but people wanted to
test it on a staging
environment, but if it is not
free, then you are blocked.  And
now we have more than staging
environment for a feature
branch.
So I will quick to a demo for
that.
Perfect.
So I will run every single
application here, and the
Dockerfile, with engine X, and
we are just e changing  --
exchanging the index ht l file
there.  I have the Kubernetes
definitions that I need, you put
in the selves, service, you put
in the labels that you want to
use, you probably want to use an
ingress controller now, and we
have deployment.  We are using
templating to get it into our
yama file.
And we have the deployer file,
so a bit like TravisCI, we are
looking at that as an
inspiration, and what name
space, what containers are
needing to be built, and we
configure to CI to trigger the
CI pipeline.
And now, let's make a change
here.
In the html file, I will create
a new
branch.
Now it is
1307.
I commit the file, and say,
hello, GDD.
I will push it, and now, so you
can see the master branch is
already deployed.
Everything works fine, and the
demo gods listened to my
prayers.
There it is.
So the new deployment, it is the
same name space and prefix.  I
will give it a few seconds,
because the load balancing is
throttl throttling, we need to
give a little bit of time to
show it
works.  This is the master
branch.
You can see that it works.
And you can -- okay.
So, I will open this, it takes a
little bit of time to re-load.
So you get a feature branch for
every environment, an
environment for every feature
branch when you are developing,
automatically.
(Applause).
Okay, let's go back to the
presentation.
So these things all fit very
well together in and help us
solve the problems that we have
because every company is unique
and sometimes you have to change
things and there is no
one-size-fits-all solution and
Kubernetes gives you the tools
to solve your problems.
So what does our infrastructure
look like? So not everything is
running Kubernetes yet, but we
have 60 namespaces for 12 teams.
We have 800 containers running
on 32 nodes.
We have multiple production
services, including two mission
critical
ones, which push 100MBs of
traffic at peak.
I think that Kubernetes is one
of the most exciting projects in
the open-source project space
since Linux itself, there is
such a supportive community and
a lot of great stuff going on.
You should go to it, if you are
looking to solve problems.
So thank you, if you have any
questions or want to chat about
Kubernetes, you can find
us on the third floor after
this talk.
Thank you very much.
(Applause).
Test.  Test.
DANIELLE: Hello, everyone.  It's
great to see you all here.
Thank you so much for joining my
session.  The year ahead in
global tech policy.  My name is
Danielle and I'm on the public
policy team here at Google.  So
in addition to introducing what
we do on the public policy team
and how we can help you, this
session is going to be a
whirlwind tour, if you will,
through some of the big issues
that we're thinking about at
Google.  Issues that are at the
intersection of technology and
public policy.
So there's a lot that we could
cover today, but I'm going to
highlight a few issues that
developers in particular will be
impacted with.  And flag some
opportunities for you to make a
difference on these issues.  So
just to get started, a bit about
me.  I'm a lawyer.  Sorry.  But
I've spent much of my time
practicing international law in
the U.S. Federal Government.
But before I made the mistake of
going to law school, I was an
electrical  engineer.  So as a
public policy adviser at Google,
I get to explore the
intersections between two areas
that I'm actually really
passionate about.  So this is
the only code that I get to put
up on the screen today.  But I
just wanted to point out that I
get the significance of the
infamous leftbad code that broke
the Internet a few years back.
But also the obscure legal
reference here.  And if you're
interested in it, see me
averwards and we can chat.
As I said, I lead global public
policy around two topics in
particular relevant to
developers.  One is the Android
operating system and related
platforms like Android auto and
Android Wear.  And our thought
leadership on the Internet of
things.  So we're going to focus
on what we see as having a
real, immediate impact on
developers.  But I'm happy to
talk about any public policy
topic that you'd like if you're
interested after this
presentation.
Okay.  So let's just get to it.
What is tech public policy
anyway?  So I'm going to start
with a bit of background.  Now,
when you say "Public  policy,"
it can sound pretty abstract.
Maybe you think of a bunch of
folks in powdered wigs,
perhaps, in a room.  Or a bunch
of folks writing a bill
together in a slow process.
This is a portrait depicting the
signing of the U.S. Declaration
of  Independence.  Obviously
these folks never heard of
GitHub.  It's 1776.  Or maybe
your favorite political TV show,
House of Cards or Yes,
Minister.  My life is nothing
like those.  Most folks think
public policy is something
outside of the world of
technology.  That is the basic
assumption.  There's policy, and
then there's tech.
But that is a big assumption.
As an engineer, I think that the
usual idea is that you should
just build great products and
let the chips fall where they
may.  There's a tendency to
think about products as being
dependent upon users rather than
larger outside forces.  But, of
course, lawmakers and policy
makers are thinking about
technology all the time.  You
might remember the SOPA/PIPA,
that's the stop online privacy
act and protect IP debates.
Those were occurring a few years
back.  So that was focused on
legislation in the United
States.  But these initiatives
would have fundamentally changed
how content is allowed to move
around the web.  And would have
had a big impact on speech.
You might also remember some of
the battles around net
neutrality.  A debate about how
people can access services and
the speed at which they can do
so.  Various iterations of these
debates are continuing today.
Now, these discussions and
debates have an impact at every
level.  As a developer, what can
you build and what can you
launch?  As a startup, what
kinds of users can you access
and when can you access those
users?  And as a user, what can
and can't you do with the
technology that you have?  So
that's the work of public policy
.  There are new rules, laws,
and regulations and ideas for
those kinds of things  popping
up all the time.  There are
great ideas.  There are bad
ideas.  And everything in
between.
So our team plays the role of
monitoring those developments
and figuring out the
implications of those for the
greater ecosystem of which
Google is a
part.  Then we spend a lot of
time telling people about it.
That sometimes involves
explaining technology to
lawmakers or policy makers who
want to learn about a new
emerging trend.  And sometimes
involves talking to particular
groups.
Developers are particularly
important because they are a
critical part of the ecosystem.
And you're really influential
when you speak out on these
issues.  So we want feedback
from developers in particular as
we figure out our position on
many of these issues.  But I
recognize, you all have day
jobs.  You're busy, important
people.  And you're too busy
trying to make sure that you
make great products and that
they work to pay attention to
the myriad of developments that
happen in the public policy
world.  A lot of it is dense
legalese, a lot of it is
regulations, a lot of it's
things that are promulgated into
the future.  That's not
something you want to spend a
lot of time focus on, on the
day-to-day.  So we think it's
important to lower the cost to
you for finding out and taking
action on all of these policy
initiatives.
So let's jump into it.  As I
mentioned, the world is big and
the universe of public policy
issues around technology is also
very big.  And I just wantedded
to pick three topics that are
at the top of mind for us here
at Google that are likely going
to have the biggest impact on
developers in the coming months.
So the Internet of Things.
Fragmentation of the Android
ecosystem, and fair use of APIs.
Okay.  So let's start with the
Internet of  Things.  Or IoT.
So I'm sure you've all heard of
IoT, but let's face it, it's
kind of a buzzword.  Really it
refers to the fact, if you break
it down, to the idea that
everything -- big and small --
is converging into becoming one
connected computer.  And these
things can take lots of
different shapes beyond the
phones and laptops that we're
accustomed to these days.  So we
don't think that the future is
going to be some sci-fi-looking
world, but instead, might look
something like this.  Just
devices that are seamlessly
integrated into every day life.
Now, IoT is a buzzword, it
doesn't mean much by itself.
But for policy makers in
particular, the ubiquity of IoT
devices raises all sorts of new
concerns.  So how should these
devices be secured against
people with malicious intent?
How should they be made to
protect user privacy?  How
should devices signal that
things are going right or going
wrong to those people who own
those devices or who are
maintaining them?  So how should
we think about these problems?
How should we approach these
large topics?  So one approach
is rather old fashioned.  Which
is to say we use the law to
shape the behavior of people who
are making and coding these
products.  That would be you.
And, indeed, lots of policy
makers around the world are
thinking about these questions,
and they're starting to consider
regulations.  The recent DDoS
attacks which involved IoT
devices that took down some
popular Internet sites are a
pretty good example of how these
things can catch the attention
of lawmakers and policy makers
around the world.  And, of
course, this is why it matters
to you.  But this picture isn't
just about lawmakers.  This is
an area in which the people who
are  designing these
technologies are going to play a
big role.
So this is Lawrence Lessig, he
is a professor at my old law
school.  You might remember him
from creative commons or his
recent ill-fated attempt to run
for President of the United
States.  He is actually most
known in the public policy world
for thinking about the various
forces that can influence human
behavior.  So law is one force.
But also  norms and markets and
code.  So in certain
situations, some levers are
going to be more powerful than
others.  And we think that, for
the Internet of Things, code is
going to be particularly
powerful because the space is
moving so fast.  And the
standards and conventions that
developers land on will be the
template for the norms and laws
that follow.
So if ubiquity is the challenge
in the IoT space, then trust is
the solution.  So at Google we
have been thinking about three
principles that should guide the
IoT space.  Interoperability,
security and privacy, and the
need for new  interfaces.  So
with respect to
interoperability, we are
constantly considering how we
can develop and support open
protocols that would allow
devices to connect easily to one
another.  With respect to
privacy and security, we are
thinking about what controls
actually need to be in place.
Taking into account the
diversity and the various use
cases for a plethora of IoT
devices even yet to be invented.
And with respect to the human
interface, we are thinking about
the implications for
transparency or consent, control
and choice around data.
Particularly when the IoT device
may have no screen or keyboard
for users to interact with.
So this is something that we are
really looking for developer
feedback on.  No one has all the
answers.  But people who are
closest to this technology have
the most practical experience.
So in sum, we really think that
developers are going to be
setting the norms for this new
IoT ecosystem.  And the
practices that you develop will
guide policy and law as it's
developed.
So next up I want to talk about
fragmentation and the Android
ecosystem and how it intersects
with the law.  I'll talk a
little bit about how this
impacts developers in
particular, and what you guys
can do about it.  So for this
story, it's worth going back to
the early days of Andy Ruben and
Android in the late 2000s.
Ancient times.  I  know.  And
for those of you who are too
young to remember or are just
living in the present and
seeing out future developments
that have happened -- or will
happen -- with devices, I think
it's really important to
remember.  It was really
difficult to create apps for
mobile devices back then.  So
first of all, there are millions
of users that weren't
harnessing the potential of the
mobile devices they had.  The
computers in their pockets
because the software just wasn't
good enough.  Mobile phones had
had really limited
functionality.  They had
relatively low usage.  And many
users wouldn't even try to get
on the Internet.  If
you remember how hard it was to
get on the Internet and do
something useful back then.
That was a real issue.
And the mobile industry was
plagued with what we call "
Walled gardens."  This created
unlimited opportunities for app
developers to get their apps on
to the devices and into the
hands of consumers.  So our
objective was develop an open
operating system that would
benefit all of the parts of the
ecosystem.  The phone
manufacturers, the app
developers, and just every day
people using phones.
So this meant developing an
operating system with some
common protocols that anyone
could pick up and use for their
own purposes.  And would allow
the same app to work across
different phones by different
manufacturers.  The goal of
Android was to turbo charge the
mobile development space by
aligning the standards around an
open source  operating system.
And as they say, that was
super-effective.
We have some amazing stats about
the state of the Android
ecosystem.  And these are a
little  dated, but I'm sure
you'll agree, we have more than
400 different manufacturers,
more than 1.4 billion Android
devices worldwide and more than
$14 billion paid to developers
since the launch of Android.
But as the ecosystem got bigger
and bigger, and I don't need to
tell you this, really, the
ecosystem also became
increasingly fragmented.
So this is a visualization from
Open Signal.  It shows the great
variety of Android devices --
which is excellent for consumers
and those who like choice --
but it also shows all of the
fragmentation that is in the
Android space.  So
in short, the  openness of the
system itself generated
fragmentation as Android grew
into more and more contexts.
So the result is higher costs in
ensuring performance on each
kind of Android device.  So Anna
Mocha had a photo being passed
around a while back.  It shows
all of the devices they keep on
hand to make sure that their
games and products run across
all of the possible Android
devices.  And this even impacts
us.  Little known fact is that
when we were developing Google
Maps, we had a closet full of
phones that we were testing them
on.
So that isn't all.
Fragmentation can impact
security.  Now, Android is a
very secure platform.  We work
to keep those 1.4 billion
Android devices safe.  And we
start with the core Android
platform as a safe space for
that.  Android is strengthened
by the regular security updates
for the platform, for
applications, for the device
themselves.  And it's constantly
evolving security services that
monitor and protect the system.
But fragmentation does make it
harder to ensure security
updates reach everyone.  And
it's doubly hard to ensure that
those devices incorporate the
latest patches quickly.  So this
certainly impacts users.  But
it also impacts the ecosystem
more deeply -- namely you --
since developers need to spend
more time and resources to
ensure security.  And another
big issue is that security
failures can easily harm a
developer's reputation.
So as an open operating system,
the interesting and exciting
design challenge here is how we
balance openness, which is in
part what generated so much
success for so many who use the
Android platform and in the
Android ecosystem with
interoperability.  So these
decision and those tradeoffs had
a huge impact on developers in
their day-to-day lives.  So we
have a few levers for
ensuring interoperability.
One, for example, is our Nexus
and Pixel phones.  Those really
serve as an attempt to give the
Android platform a method for
the operating system to be
uniform.  But the strongest
lever that we have to
ensure interoperability is our
relationship with phone makers.
They get impacted with
fragmentation too.  So we make
agreements with them to ensure
certain practices that protect
interoperability.  So the worry
is, without the ability to use
these  anti-fragmentation
agreements, the Android
ecosystem will continue to
fragment in ways that are really
unsustainable over time.  So
eventually you could imagine
devices diverging so much that
it becomes difficult to tell
whether or not a begin app will
run when you download it.
We also think that it might
particularly impact smaller
developers that don't have the
resources to deal with big
cabinets full of phones.  So you
may have heard that regulators
are interested in these
agreements too because they have
a big impact on the mobile
ecosystem.  At issue is whether
or not these types of agreements
should be allowed at all.
These inquiries that we get from
policy makers really give us a
chance to better understand what
they're interested in and a
chance to talk about how the
open source ecosystem and
Android really works.   But, of
course, it isn't just about
Google.  Developers are a big
part of the picture here.
It turns out that regulators are
just as interested in the
developers that make the Android
ecosystem great.  So how do you
balance
openness and interoperability?
That is a question that's not
just for policy makers, but for
developers too.  And the policy
makers really need to hear from
you.
So the last topic that I will
briefly touch on is fair use of
APIs.  So the surest way for me
to get booed off the stage, if
you're not asleep yet, is for me
to launch into the intricacies
of copyright law.  So I will
just simply say this: for
decades developers have relied
on the open nature of APIs to
build their products and to have
reimplemented those APIs to
create new software.  Think
about, for example, the C
standard library  API.  That has
reimplemented countless times
to allow differing operating
systems to work with programs in
C.  So many developers have
found that when they can freely
reimplement an API without
getting a costly license, they
can create compatible software
that maybe the original creator
had not ever envisioned before.
So we think the openness of
APIs supports innovation.  And
that's innovation everywhere
from incumbents to startups.
Currently there is debate about
whether APIs should be
copyrightable.  And if so
whether a doctrine called "Fair
use" could be used so that
licenses would not be necessary
in certain contexts.  So the
question is, what does the world
look like if developers have to
get a license before
reimplementing an API?  Or if
they can't rely on fair use
doctrine.  I'm sure you're
building products and tools
every day that can provide
concrete examples about how
decisions policy makers make on
copyrightbility and the
application of fair use would
really impact the world.  What
products might get bullet and
what might not if you have to
seek licenses to reimplement
APIs?  That would be something
that would be really great for
you to communicate in a
practical way to policy makers.
So I'm going to wrap up soon.  I
really hope that if you take
anything away from this
presentation, it's really how
important you are to these
debates and how important these
debates are to you.  So right
now, if you're here in the
audience with us, we really
invite you to visit the Google
Developer Video Studio which is
on the third floor here, and
tell us your experiences
developing with Android.  We'll
be there for the next couple of
hours.  And if you want to ask
me other public policy
questions, I would be happy to
engage.
There we would love to record
your story.  Tell us about the
work that you're doing.  How
Android has helped you do it.
And please give us your honest
feedback.  Maybe there's some
things you agreed with me on
here, some different point of
view that you want to raise.
That is completely okay.  It's
your honest
in' opinions and thoughts about
these issues that help us figure
out where we should be.  And
for your time, I think we have a
small gift for the first 40 or
so of you that are able to make
it up and share your thoughts
with us.  If you don't have a
chance to stop by today, there
are other things you can do to
contribute to the debate.  Feel
free to Tweet and share on
social media some of the ideas
you heard here.  We have a photo
booth that we would love for
you to visit and share that on
social media as well.  To have
people know that you're
interested in these issues so
policy makers can start thinking
more fully about how developers
might be
integrated into this
conversation.
So that's it.  Thank you so much
for your time.
[ Applause ]
STEPHEN: Good afternoon.  My
name is Stephen  Fluin and I'm
on the developer Angular team at
Google.  I have been entransed
by tools throughout my career.
The right
tools used in the right way
have the ability to improve our
lives as developers, but also to
increase the quality of our
work.  Part of the reason I
joined Google was to help
developers find and adopt great
tools from across the
ecosystem.  We have heard a lot
about progressive web
applications.  Part of what we
have heard is some of the great
case decease.  About the
outcomes we get from adopting
these technologies.  And we have
also heard about some of the
ways these improve the user
experience.  I want to peel back
the onion of PWAs and the way
that we build progressive web
applications and the way that
tools can help us do that.  I'm
going through this in basically
four parts.
First, I'm going it start off
with an introduction to the
state of progressive web apps as
they are today.  Then dive into
some of the goals of the tools.
Why do we build them?  What
are the philosophies.  And then
single page applications and the
libraries and frameworks that
exist today to use these things.
And then we'll end with some
best practices that you can take
back as you start  adopting
these tools and look at adding
progressive web applications to
your workflow.  So let's start
by looking at the state of PWA
tooling as it is right now in
September of 2017.  We're all
chasing after the perfect
progressive we can application,
but a lot of us come from very
different journeys.  Some of us
already have large applications.
Some of us have Greenfield
projects where we can experiment
and try new things.  When we
talk about the perfect
progressive web app, it's three
things.  Building applications
that are fast, reliable and
engaging.  And when we combine
this with thinking about the
tooling that exists for us as
developers, we're  looking at
how do we get the best developer
experience for providing our
users the best experience.  The
best DX for the best UX.
So what can tooling do to help
with these problems?  Well,
whether we talk about our users,
their time is very, very
important.  As we have heard
many times throughout the
conference, even seconds or
milliseconds of time that you
make your users wait for your
application or pieces of
functionality can cost your
business money.  You can lose
your conversions every time.  We
also talk about bandwidth.  In
many cases and in many user
environments, the amount of
bandwidth that your application
takes is a direct decision
factor in terms of whether or
not they're going to use your
product or service.
Additionally, tools can do some
very interesting things.  By
giving a tool an understanding
of the browsers that you're
looking to target, and by
combining that with an
understanding of what tool or
browser the user is using to
access your application, we can
send down just the right code at
the right time.
Additionally, push notifications
are a really great way of
building engagement with PWAs.
And tooling can help us
understand these things a little
bit better.  As developers, a
lot of the time we're writing
code and maintaining code.  And
so using  PWAs to generate code
for us -- or using tools to
generate code for PWAs -- can be
a huge impact for our lives.
And lastly, tools really focus
on  allowing us to take
advantage of best practices by
giving a deep understanding,
using tools like  Lighthouse
that expose froms across the
visit best practices collected
by the Chrome team.
Some of the technology behind
PWAs include the manifest which
we'll talk a little bit about,
the service worker -- which I'll
talk a lot about -- but it
comes down to you building great
applications.  Tools can only
do so much to take advantage of
the latest and greatest
capabilities was browser.  You
still need to be thinking about
your use cases and worrying
about your users.  So let's talk
about the web application
manifest.  It's designed to let
browsers and the web at large
know about your application.
We're really trying to elevate
the code from a single page
that's served at a single time,
or a set of JavaScript and HTML
into the concept of a collective
application that we know
something about.  It has themes,
it's got icons.  It's got a
starting place.  We can tell the
browser or the device how it
should be accessing the site and
how it should be presenting to
the user.  Some tools can do
things like default generation.
They can give us a manifest
that we can then easily
configure.  Other tools will
actually guide you through the
entire process of making
decisions.
Service workers are the
underlying API in browsers that
give us these modern super
powers for building progressive
web applications.  By adding a
service worker to my app, I can
do a lot of cool things.  I can
proxy and intersect all the HTTP
requests.  I can decide if I
want to be serving from the
Internet, a local cache, or
general content stored in the
service worker.  But service
wokers have a relatively long
life cycle, and caching can be
done at any of the stages.  If
the user first visits the page
and we're rendering, after the
service worker is installed and
we're given a chance to actually
go and cache these things.  Or
even later, maybe when a user is
visiting a page for a second or
third time.  We can make these
distinctions at each of the
points of the life  cycle, but
tools
can help us make decisions.
Now file caching.  Hey, as a
developer, I want to cache all
the assets from the application
as part of the installation
process
because it's so important to my
app.
Or maybe I see caching as a nice
to have for the application and
I want to install after the
application has installed by
service worker.  This can be
helpful by taking some of the
work that's being done by the
browser out of the critical path
for rendering, giving users a
great experience.  And run-time
caching.  We don't always know
all of the data our application
is going to need when we write
it.  A lot of the data is coming
from servers and backends.  And
you could say, hey, I want to
cache these things so if the
user is going offline, they can
access all of the content they
have previously seen.  Finally,
there's also advanced caching
strategies.  Because by
combining our knowledge of our
applications with our tools
knowledge of the user, we can
actually do far more advanced
things that really drive great
user experiences.
Another technology that we
really want our  tools to help
us with is push notifications.
As developers, there's a lot of
work that can be done if we want
to take advantage of it.  And
there's best practices that the
browsers are leaning  towards.
One of these best practices is
we want different behaviors for
push notifications whether we're
using the application actively
on the device or whether the
service worker is being woken up
behind the scenes, when the
user is not interacting with the
device.  When the user is not
interacting with the device, we
want to show a notification.
But when they're live and
engaging.  These sorts of best
practices can be baked in via
tooling.  Another thing that I
care a lot about is code
generation.  Where we want to
giveout code that's going to
help you get the work done
faster.  Good tools that do good
code generation are going to be
fast by  default, great by
default and they can do things
like help you with your build
pipeline.
So help you write code and ship
that great code to your users
with all of the sorts of metrics
and things that you need to
understand how your users are
going to consume your
applications.
I see code generation as a very
interesting idea.  Because it
combines this idea to give a
developer a great experience by
default without eliminating any
of their flexibility or control
of what they actually ship to
users.  So when we talk about
PWAs, there's a few different
ways that Sam talked about
yesterday in terms of building
them and adding to the existing
workflow.  Maybe write a new app
from scratch, taking advantage
of PWAs.  Maybe I'm going to
rewrite one feature of the
application and take advantage
of PWAs fully.  Or maybe I want
to look at it a little bit
differently and add one PWA
feature to my entire
application.  Things are a
little bit simpler when we talk
about both the generic tools and
the framework and
library-specific tools.  Because
typically, as a developer, I'm
targeting that library or
framework for my entire
application.  And because of
this, it's much easier for us to
take the best of PWA and apply
it holistically to my
application all at one
time.  But it's still possible
to take advantage of some of
these tools and build a fully
custom service worker or PWA
implementation that follows my
business needs and the needs of
my users.
One of the really fantastic
tools is Chrome.  And the
developer tools that we have
been building into them.  I'm
going to come back to this a
couple times.  Because the
application tab in the developer
tools is one of your best
assets for understanding what's
going on when it comes to
building a PWA.  It's there that
you can bypass the service
worker for network calls so that
you make sure you're  getting
the most fresh data.  You can
understand the life cycle.  Is
there a service worker that's
pending install?  One that's
already been installed in what's
the state of my cache?  Can I
look and see what has been
cached and what the status is?
And the Chrome developer tools
are awesome because we baked in
some of the best practices such
as  Lighthouse.  Now, using
Lighthouse, I can figure  out,
am I building a great
progressive web application?  Is
my application doing well on
performance?  Can I broaden any
audience by taking advantage of
more accessibility best
practices?  And overall, what
are the best practices that we
have discovered across the
ecosystem that I could be
taking advantage of in my app?
So we have a few generic tools.
These are  tools that can be
used for any web application
that exists today.  And one of
the best for doing this is
called Workbox.  This is a
project from the Chrome team
that takes the best of what
we've got in terms of our
understanding of the use cases
and the needs of developers and
packages that in a very easy to
use library.  Workbox is
fantastic in the way that it
embeds offline caching, offline
analytics and now APIs coming
available in browsers such as
background sync.  Background
sync is an important concept.
It allows us not only to get the
freshest data when users are
interacting with the
application, but we can do it
behind the scenes.  The moment
the user accesses the
information -- even in offline
mode -- we can give the freshest
data they expect.
I love Webpack.  There's a lot
of tools with PWA attributes.
One of these is offline plugin
for Webpack.  Offline plugin
focuses on the file impact of
service worker and PWAs.  You
can do ahead of time caching,
give me the files up front.
Deferred caching -- get the
files later.  Or make the files
optional and base on user
behavior to cache the  files at
the right times in the right way
.
Another fantastic project to
look at with PWA is from
Pinterest.  It's on their GitHub
.   Pinterest/service worker.
These are a collection of
utilitieses for creating and
testing service worker.  Not
only code tools that give you a
service worker under the hood
that helps you move faster as a
developer, but they have done
something interesting.  They
have built out a mock
environment generator that
allows you to do testing of your
service  worker.  And this has
historically been a little bit
of a problem because newness of
the APIs.  And sometimes the
browser is ignoring the backend
entirely.  So mocking out these
and testing them can be very
important for ensuring that we
have fantastic user experiences.
Another tool that you should be
aware of that you're going to
see all over the place is a set
of tools called sw-precash and
sw-toolbooks.  These were
utilities for building service
workers.  They have the same
goals and values as Workbox, but
less modular and extensible.
The team wanted to collect the
tools and reflect on the best
practices we have learned and
bake those into the new tools.
So  sw-precache and sw-toolbox
have for the most part been
we placed by Workbox.  But sw
-precache is still a fantastic
tool for building PWAs.  Another
tool to have in your tool mitt
hit is HackerNews PWA.  Or
HNPWA.com.  This is a Website
where we're collecting the best
practices across a number of
tools,  libraries and frameworks
for building progressive web
applications.  For each
submission we track both the
speed as well as some of the
capabilities of it.  There's
tools from projects like React,
Firebase, and Angular.  There's
more than 20 implementations of
the hacker
news client and tried to show
off the PWA capabilities in a
way that's open-source and you
can take advantage of and learn
from as a developer.
So now let's get into a little
bit about the goals and the
philosophy behind these tools.
I like to think that technology
tools are really about
simplifying the mental model in
a good way.  It's very easy to
do this wrong.  Because what
we're doing under the hood is
we're minding new abstractions
for concepts that have existed
before in lower levels, but we,
as developers, can't hold all of
the complexity in our heads at
one time.  We have to focus on
smaller subsets in the tasks we
are trying to accomplish.  And
tools are fantastic at taking an
abstraction and saying, here is
the thing that I can help you
with.  Additionally, tools can
help with edge cases.  And
finally, tools can help you save
time.  Let's dig into these a
little bit more.
So when we simplify mental
models, this is something that
we often have to do.  One of the
common programming jokes,
there's two unsolved problems in
computer science, naming things
and caching validation.
Caching is a very, very hard
topic.  So if we focus via tools
more on use cases than
underlying implementation, the
tools can help us with that to a
huge degree.  The service
worker life cycle I find to be a
little bit difficult.  So,
again, focusing on use cases,
the tools can help with that.
The last is an interesting
conversation that I have with
developers.  Does web
development feel like I'm used
to?  We're mapping few concepts
into concepts that came
previously as developers.  I
talk to developers that are
stuck in the web development
from five or six years ago
because they haven't been able
to take advantage of the newer
capabilities and the new APIs in
the browser.  So good tooling
should be teaching you the
mental  models and guiding you
into the new
world while still empowering you
to be effective from day one.
There's also a lot of edge cases
that end up coming up that you
might not expect when you start
using progressive web apps or
service workers.  A lot of us
talked about intermittent
connectivity and use cases.
What if your app loses
connectivity during the service
worker install?  An
implementation might fail out
and say I can't use the assets.
Let's uninstall, throw away
what we've got and try again on
the next load.  But you can do
something different.  Some of
the tools will allow you, for
example, keep some of the cache
files through validation.
They're using checks to know
that they've got the files and
understand the integrity of
those files.  We have talked
about a lot of offline use
cases, but there's online use
cases.  What in your user has
full connectivity.  What I
believe is an antipattern, the
box that says the object is
updated, click to refresh.  This
wasn't on the web because
applications were always fresh.
Now in the modern web, because
we have the
new capabilities, we have
introduced that if I update my
application every day, perhaps
with a continuous integration
system, I don't want my user to
be constantly assaulted with
this click to refresh just so
they're getting the freshest
content of my app.
We also build applications now
in much larger environments.
Many times, you may be building
the frontend of an application,
but you have no control over the
backend of an application.  And
so as y looking at adopting
things like service worker, you
may want to be caching files.
But maybe the cache headers
coming back from your API aren't
what you expect or need to
build out the frontend.  So you
can look at things like tools to
say, hey, maybe I need to
override the cache or ignore
them and supply a different
policy that supports my frontend
in a way that my backend can't.
And finally, we talk about
saving time.  As developers, we
write a lot of code.  But we
also have projects that have a
lot of DevOps.  It's not as easy
adds writing code anymore.  How
am I going to write this?
Build this and combine with what
other developers are doing and
ship to the user?  Finding the
right abstractions and tools at
each of these stages is very
important.
So now let's get into the world
of single page applications.  So
libraries, frameworks and
platforms, oh, my.  So I'm going
to go through these five
specific tools.  I apologize to
anyone not on the list, there
are more tools than I can count
and more frameworks than I can
go over in the limited time we
have.
But each of these share a number
of things.  So each of these
tools use some sort of CLI in
order to empower developers to
be more effective more  quickly.
So let's go into each of these
.  So in the React world, we
have create-react-app which is a
fantastic CLI.  If you're using
this CLI, you'll see it creates
a service worker and manifest
by default.  It has a cache-
first strategy under the hood so
you get the are fastest
experience possible.  So for all
of these examples, I'm going to
use Yarn.  You could use NPM or
any package management tool to
fetch from the repository.  But
installing
is Yarn global add.  You
install create-react-app.  I'm
going to run it and give a it a
project name.  Then see the end
of the folder and run a build
command.  What this will give e
get me is a basic hello world,
welcome to React application
that is awesome in terms of
develop straiting how we get
started quickly and give
developers the freedom and
flexibility to get into their
application
and start adding  functionality
right away.
And one thing that is beautiful
to see, the moment you see that
application in your web browser,
a service worker has been
installed and loaded.  So it is
a PWA out of the box in a very
fantastic way.  Let's now talk a
little bit about the Preact
project and CLI.  This goes a
little bit further in terms of
helping developers take
advantage of the modern web.  It
has the standard app correction
but will also create an app
shell for your index.HTML.  It
can make sure it's pre-rendered
as HTML and you can ship down to
the browser
to increase perceived
performance, an important
metric.  It's also  browserware,
so if you tell it what browsers
to target, it can add the
appropriate prefixes.  One thing
that's fantastic about the
preact CLI, they have
preconfigured for Firebase and
Server Push.  Combining its
knowledge with your application
and the best practices across
the web in had terms of which
files should be pushed down to
the browser and those waited for
or requested
when needed by the user.  And
baking that into the Firebase
Hosting configuration.  All of
the CLI  is using XW precache
under the hood today.  Just like
before, I'm going to add the
preact-cli and run preact create
and see the folder and run the
build.  Here, out of the box,
we're going to get a beautiful
material-designed style app.
Hello world.  And one of the
cool things about this
application is that it includes
routing by default so you can
see one of these very common
patterns and get started more
quickly.
Next, I want to talk about
Polymer and the Polymer CLI.
Polymer does things differently.
So while they have the
manifest generation and the
optional service worker, they
actually do a set of
distributions for you.  And this
is something that's unique to
how they built their CLI.  When
you run a build, you won't get a
single set of JavaScript that
you ship down to the browser.
They're going to give three
options.  An ES5 bundled version
that will work in any browser.
And also an ES6 or ES2015
version that's smaller and more
performant if the browsers have
optimized for ES2015.  Most
have.  And then an unbundled
code.  And they're helping you
take advantage of the latest and
greatest from the browsers and
leaving behind some of the
legacy that
we had to support with ES5 in
the past.  One thing that's nice
about the Polymer CLI, they
have PRPL defaults.  They
believe in the great injuries
experiences.  I'm going to
install the polymer-cli.  And
run it and run Polymer in
it.  It's going to give me a set
of choices of which starter
kit.  There's several options,
and this one here out of the
box, polymer-2-starter-kit.  And
as soon as I set up the
projects, I can run Polymer
build.  I'm going to get
routeing and material design
styling that out of the box gets
me started much quicker.
And as we like to see, it's a
service worker out of the box.
Next, I'm going to talk a little
bit about view.  So there's two
projects at play here.  There's
the Vue CLE as well as the
Vuejs-templates for PWA.  It
handles manifest and service
worker and app shell generation.
And one of the nice things
about the Vue CLI, is
intelligently loads the bits of
your application as needed.  So
if you have lazy-loaded routes,
which chunks, based on a user
request, with need to load right
away and which are asynchronous
and deferred to later.  Using
the new CLI  is straightforward.
Install the CLI and run
vulnerabilities, and choose the
template and the project name.
The Vue CLI  is fantastic in a
guided setup.  It's going to be
asking you questions about the
application and how you want to
serve  users.  And as you're
going, teach you the different
decisions you have to make as a
developer.  Then I'm going to
install the dependencies and run
a build command.  Out of the
box, we have a helpful
tutorial.  Hey, here's some
links that will get you started
as a Vue developer.  And, again,
we have the beautiful service
worker.
Lastly, I'm going to talk a
little bit about Angular CLI.
The Angular CLI handles app
creation and service worker
generation.  One thing that's a
little bit different about the
Angular CLI, instead of using
JavaScript to configure the
service worker, is has a
declarative file, NGSW.  Another
thing about the Angular
implementation and support for
service workers, they have
wrapped push  notifications as a
service that you can inject
into your application in order
to do things like  registering
for push notifications or to
observe or listen to on
observable that gives you the
publishers that comes from your
application or understanding the
life cycle entitles that are
coming from a service worker.
So use PWAs with Angular, you're
going to install the @
angular/cli, the
ng new.  And flip a flag saying
I would like a service worker
worker, please.  And then when
you run a production build,
you're going to automatically
get service worker included in
the application that's going to
create the static files
generated as part of the Webpack
build process.  And you can
declare those saying these are
the files to dynamically cache,
these are the files you can
ignore.  So on.  When you
generate a project like this,
it's going to give you a short
hello world page that has the
necessary links to get you
further started as an Angular
developer.  And, again, we have
the service worker.  The Angular
team has decided to ship
basically a single service
worker that is entirely reliant
on the configuration file.  It's
on disk, but you can modify it
to your heart's content.  It's
to show everything that the
service worker can do via that
file so you can configure
easily.
There's a few other projects
that I want to mention briefly
in the remaining time we have.
There's as, called PWA.rocks.
There's a PWA builder you can
find online.  It's a web-based
interface for generating
manifests.  You'll be able to
upload images and it will
generate the right sizes,
generate the JSON for you and
help you with  questions to
understand what's going into the
web manifest.  And then ask you
how do you want to generate a
service worker?  It will ask
based on the use case.  For
example, are you trying to cache
thes as sets so it works
offline?  Or more dynamic, we
just cache what the application
uses, so as a user touches
things, it can be accessed
offline.  And there's a set of
tools, ng-PWA
Tools that let you take
advantage of server side
rendering.
And lastly, best practices for
building and debugging these
things.  Remember, remember,
remember to check the
applications tab.  I have heard
stories of developers restarting
their browsers, uninstalling
Chrome, reformatting their
machines because they can't
understand why their application
isn't refreshing.  Service
workers are a powerful API, but
favoring performance over
freshness, it can break the
refresh cycle.  Rob Dodson --
bitly -- and another
recommendation in terms of best
practices, make sure you're
following the tools.  Tools are
useful because they provide
abstractions.  But if those are
the wrong abstractions, you can
spend more time fighting the
tools because you're going
against their intention.
Whenever you adopt a new tool,
try to understand what the tool
is trying to do.  Try to
understand the pieces of the
workflow that it's trying to
automate.  You're going to have
a much better time if you're
using tools the way they intend,
so as you continually
evolving with they don't
continually break you.  While
the Chrome tools are fantastic,
I would recommend you don't rely
on them as the only way that
you debug and build your
applications.  Throttling is one
of the cool features where I
can say, hey, give me an
emulated 3G connection or an
offline connection.  But they
aren't enough and won't create
all the scenarios that users are
on the bus or on a plane, for
example.  It's important to note
that as of today -- I believe
this is true -- the offline
check box doesn't affect web
sockets.  If you're building an
application with Firebase, for
example, pulling down the data
via the web sockets.  It will
not test the service worker with
the data because the data might
come back when you expect it
not to.
One of the other cool techniques
that's just being developed
right now is the idea of having
end-to-end tests for your
service worker.  It's possible
and important to think about how
we understand the state of our
service worker as we're building
applications.  There's two
projects to check out.  The
first is the Pinterest project
that I talked about where
they're mocking out the
environments.  You can do things
in a more hermetic way.  And
they're building out a PWA
harness where we can use the
standard end-to-end tools and
using browser implementation
with the debugging mode, and
check and verify and change the
service worker status in the way
that the user could be doing.
The lest recommendation I have
is really make sure that you're
staying up to date.  Service
workers are a fantastic API that
are on millions -- and possibly
I think that's billions of
devices today.  But it's
continuing to expand and evolve
as the web ecosystem always
does.  A great example of this
is we have seen work done in
Safari to support service
workers.  What that support
looks like?  We don't actually
know.  But it's important to
understand and use the latest
and greatest tools so you're
reaching as many people as you
can and empowering as many users
are fantastic experiences.  So
I would ask you, really, just
give these tools a try and let
us know what your experiences
are with them.  We all want to
make the web a better place.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Hell low and welcome,
everyone.  Thank you for joining
us.  We are excited to be here
and really appreciate the
efforts especially after  lunch.
We know it's not as easy as
the early morning hours.  We are
here today to share with you
what's new and cool and
interesting in the new platform
of the Google Assistant.  At
Google, as we heard in the
keynote earlier, we believe that
the future is AI first.  What
does it mean?  It means that we
invested a lot in machine
learning, natural language
processing and understanding
context and what the user wants.
And it's boiling down to the
Assistant.  It's basically a way
for you to have a conversation
with Google and get things done.
And the beauty of this new
platform is that basically it's
everywhere.  So from really
small devices up to cars.  And
very soon we're going to have
many more devices.  It's going
to be  everywhere.  Why it's one
of the most important questions
that every time when we have a
new platform or a new system we
ask ourselves.  And there are
obvious questions and obvious
answers to this new platform,
like it's running everywhere,
it's very efficient.  It's a
great way to get things done.
But to me, personally, there are
two things that I think if I
were in your shoes I would look
at it very carefully.  One is
the productivity aspect.  You
could really help your users
interact with your service and
get to the result that they want
efficiently and without too
much trouble.  And second, like
the photo op there, it's blue
ocean right now.  So think about
the early days in each big new
revolution, you could be one of
the first there.  And we'll
touch on it later.  It's a great
way for you to be there with the
quality up and then reach more
users.
So what does it mean for us as
developers?  There are lots of
new terms.  And it's great to
understand at the beginning what
we mean with each and every
one.  So first and foremost, we
have the surfaces.  Right now we
have the Google home device
which is a smart speaker that
the Assistant is  embedded in it
and it lets you talk and get
things done with it and, of
course, mobile devices,
Android, iPhones, it's embedded
there.  The Google Assistant is
basically the conversation that
you are doing with Google.  And
like we saw in the impress i
demos in the keynote, lots of
new interesting things to
communicate and to express what
is the intent and what you want
to do is get the results very
efficiently and quickly back
you.
Action on Google is the way to
expose this new Assistant
platform to third-party
developers -- so you.  So you
could tap into the investment
that we did and leverage it when
you are coming to serve your
services and product and you
handed them to your users.  The
major important aspect here to
remember is that when you
interact with the Assistant,
it's very straightforward.  It's
a conversation.  And when you
want to handle your service and
your users, you basically burst
with, okay, Google, or, hey,
Google -- talk to and then give
the specific brand name.  So
your users from then on will
move and be in your hands and
you can interact with them and
do -- and help them reach the
goal that you want to.
So how does the Assistant app
work?  And,  again, it's very
important at the beginning to
have the basic understanding of
the moving parts here and then
everything becomes much clearer.
So as you can see here in our
example, we are did a small demo
that's called Personal Chef to
give you suggestions to a recipe
based on your flavor and what
you feel like in the right
moment.  When you burst and say,
okay, Google, talk to Personal
Chef, basically you're going to
go to Google and then the magic
of language understanding and
gathering out from what the user
said, the exact intents and
entities is being done for you.
And from that moment you
basically go to your service --
here it will be Google Cloud,
but it can be any cloud service
out there -- and the user is in
your hand.  And you need to
interpret what they wanted and
return back the text.  Google
will take and produce a speech
out of it.
So all the interaction with the
users will be done through that
layer that basically is giving
you the ability to work with
nice JSON files in your server
that is easy to interpret and
work with.  But the heavy
lifting of combining and going
from text to speech is being
done through that layer.  Well,
I think the best will be just to
look at this short demo.  It
will make very clear what I just
said.
>> Sure. Hi, I'm --
>> Well, I was kind of --
[away from  microphone]
>> All right.
>> Some chicken.
>> Okay. You should try the --
[away from microphone]
>> All right. So that was a
pretty simple interaction.  It
was like a simple thing to be
having a conversation about.
But the conversation itself was
actually quite complex.  Wayne,
our developer advocate up there
said cold, warm and hot all in
the same sentence.  And the app
managed to capture the correct
one referring to the soup.  Can
you imagine writing a regular
expression or parser that would
extract meaning out of that?
There are so many difficult
cases it's pretty much
impossible for anything beyond a
trivial example.  So let's look
at some of the ways we could
build this interaction.
So one of the options is to use
the conversation API and the
actions SDK.  And in this case
your Assistant app receives a
request that contains the spoken
text from the user as a string.
So Google handles the speech
recognition for you, but you
pass the strings.  You generate
a response.  And then Google
handles speaking this back to
the user.  The thing is -- as we
just mentioned --  parsing
natural language can be really
difficult.  So fortunately we
have some tools that make
handling that type of thing a
lot easier.
API.ai is one of these.  It's
a platform
that makes it incredibly
straightforward to build
conversational experiences.  You
might not have to write any
code if you're  building
something simple.  So we're
going to give you an overview of
this today.  It's probably what
most of you should use if
you're going to implement your
own Assistant app.  So api.ai
uses a graphical experience to
have interfaces.  You put in
sentences of the way a user
might express a
certain need.  And you can
specify the values you need to
get from the user.  And then we
use machine learning to train a
model -- or we train a machine
learning model to understand the
sentences and manage the
conservation.  The key part is
you no longer need to process
raw strings.  Api.ai will do
that for you.  You can see in
the diagram where it fits in.
It handles the conversation
fulfillment in between the
Assistant itself and your
backend.
And api.ai handles the
conservation for you.  So
another way of looking at this,
the user says something, maybe
asking for a certain recipe.
The Assistant converts their
voice into text, and api.ai
receives the text string.  It
will decompose that and figure
out what it means and hand the
meaning in structured data.  You
do whatever you need to do,
like look it up in the database
and find a matching recipe,
build a response and pass it
back to the system which will
read it out to the user.
So we're going to show you a
short demo of how we would work
with api.ai to build this app.
All right.  So in api.ai we
create an intent to represent
each thing that the user might
want to do.  So in this case,
we've built an intent that
covers the user asking for a
recipe.  So I'm going to open
the intent here.  So right here
you can are see how we've
provided examples of different
ways the user might express
their desire for a recipe.  And
these examples are used to train
a machine learning model that
can recognize what the user
wants.
And as we add examples, api.ai
will  automatically pick out
important concepts that are
mentioned by the user.  So the
system actually understands many
concepts by itself.  But you
can add custom, domain-specific
information.  Like, in this
case, recipe ingredients.  So
I'm going to add a couple of
thing here is.
>> And as he types, you can see
that it will mark immediately
the entities that it
understands.  And if it doesn't
understand the entity that you
wish, you can mark it for it.
You can see here, protein and
dish type are recognized because
we have some examples beneath.
>> So another example -- so
these are all entities our
system knows about.  And api.ai
is able to pluck those from the
user statement and figure out
what nay mean.  So we can
actually also mark this
information as "Required."  So
here we've put in a cooking
speed and a dish type.  Down
here we've actually marked" Dish
type" and "Protein" and"
Vegetable" as required.  In this
case, the app is going to wait
for the user to ask if they
didn't mention it.  So I'm going
to save the intent and wait
one moment for the machine
learning model.
>> Yeah, okay.
>> Okay. So training is
completed.  So now I'm going to
enter in our test console, which
is kind of how we work while
we're developing the agent.  I
can just enter in "I want
something with beef."  So in
this case I'm specifying a
protein, but I didn't specify a
vegetable or a dish type.  So
that the system actually knows
that it expects those things and
it should prompt for them if
they weren't  supplied.  So I
can now say," Potato."  And I
still need to know a dish type.
What kind of dish do you
prefer?  Let's have a main
course.
And so now this is where we
would hand off to our backend
and we would use that structured
data to look up a recipe in the
database and return it to the
user.  So it's pretty amazing to
be able to conduct a
conversation dynamically in this
way just based on the
information the user provided on
the fly without knowing in
advance what they're going to
say.  Once the intent has
captured all of this
information, it becomes
available to use on your
backend, which is where you're
going to make stuff happen and
generate a response.  So you can
see in here, we have the action
that we resolve to, which is
the intent.  And we have this
parameter data that we captured
from the user's query.
And so because we have those
values in a structured way, we
can look those up in our backend
and return something useful.
So once we're done, it's only a
few clicks to integrate the app
with a load of different
platforms.  On the integration
tab here.  We want to integrate
with actions on Google so this
is available via the Google
Home.  And we can click here and
load up the simulator to test
this out.  So the actions on
Google Web Simulator allows us
to test out our action as if
it's running on the actual
platform.
So I can say, "Talk to my test
app."
>> All right. Let's get the
test version of my test app.
>> And so here we're seeing how
the app would be responding.
And I can say, "Let's try a
recipe with chicken
." And this is now communicating
with  api.ai in the same way
that the Google Home might  be.
So it's asking what kind of
vegetables we have.  So let's
say potato.  And, again, we want
a main course.  So you can see
how it's really easy to develop
your app with an api.ai.  Test
it out in the simulator.  And
then the magical thing is, if
you're signed into a Google Home
or the Assistant app on your
phone, this app is now
immediately available for you to
test out.  So you can try it
straightaway and make
modifications which is a really
fun work flow.  There's
not a deployment step.  This is
for building an action.  And
you should go to the  following
workshop session on building an
Assistant app to give it a try
for yourself.
So let's switch back over to our
slides and talk a little more
about the platform.
>> So we saw how we could
leverage api.ai, and the goal
with any app is to have the wow
effect and the best experience
that we can give our users.  So
let's touch a bit on what can we
do.  Before we are starting to
code our app, and it's actually
easy to do, I think one of the
most important aspects is to
dive into all the grid content
that our team produce around
design, voice, UIs.  It's
totally different topic than
what we -- or most of us are
used to in terms of graphical
user interface.  Coming to
voice, there's lots of
constraints and limitations that
we could take into
consideration.  And there's some
great you went its there like a
checklist and tips that could
really put you on the right
track when you're coming to
design the conversation and see
how the working parts are going
to work best in your specific
use case.
When we are coming to build it,
we need to take into
consideration when, like we saw
in the earlier slide, we have
different surfaces out there.
Right now we have Google Home
and mobile devices.  Soon we
will have more.  On mobile
devices we could and actually
should leverage
the real estate that the screen
is giving us.  As you can see
here in the example, say the
user wanted to get to someplace.
Google Home will tell them
where to go.  And if we have the
screen and we know it in our
app that we are now on this
surface, we could give them a
small map and a URL to get the
directions immediately.
At the most basic, you can
specify on the screen what is
the text that you are going to
speak.  And as you could see
here in the example, that we
have what will be telling to the
user and what
will be the text.  One of the
most important aspects to
remember here is that we always
want that the text will be a
summary or the executive summary
of what we will talk to the
user.  So if the user is
listening and getting the full
blown answer, and if they're
just skimming with their eyes
the screen, they still get to
see what we want.  Or the most
important aspect -- but like in
the example here, we don't need
to give them the full blown
answer.
When we have one of the options
or one of the most popular
options, one of the main design
themes that we're giving is to
lead the conversation and give
the user the ability to very
quickly go and route to the path
that they want to.  So suggests
are one of the most efficient
way to do it.  If you have
popular choices, you could
suggest it to the user.  So on
the screen they have a nice
button they can click on.  And
if we are on Google Home, you
can suggest it and the user can
choose.  They're not forced to
it, they can choose any number
out there.  But we are
suggesting what to do.  And in
our example, it could be
suggesting the most common
vegetables that are appearing in
the recipe.
Basic cards are actually quite
holistic and complex in the
sense that they're giving the
full blown image URL and text.
And it's giving you the ability
to extend the experience.  So in
our case we could show a nice,
big photo of the dish itself and
to give the user a link so that
they could open it in their app
and see what we are going to
cook.
There are many cases where you
want to set and show the user a
list of things.  And give the
user a visual selection of
what's going on with the
different types of things that
they could choose from.  And the
carousel shows big images.  The
main difference is that we have
a more limited set of items.
And the list will have smaller
images and much longer lists
that we could show the user what
are the different options.  And
in this example, you could
think about showing a couple of
different options for type of
dish.  And that would be --
let's say that the user already
chooses a chicken salad, we
could use the carousel to offer
three, four different types of
recipes for chicken salad.  On
the other hand, if we want to
show a dozen different dishes
that feature chicken as an
ingredient, we could use the
list.
>> So you might have a
conversation where you need to
know the user's name or
location.  So one example might
be if you were helping the user
find a local bookstore and you
want to know the zip code or the
post code.  So you can use our
SDK to request permissions for
the name, the course location,
and the precise location of the
user.  And when you invoke this
function, the Assistant's going
to ask the user for permission
in the voice of your app.  So
it's really seamless.  The same
is the name of the user who is
registered to the device.  The
precise location is the exact
GPS coordinates and the street
address.  And then the course
location is just the zip code or
post code and the city.
If you'd like to link a user
with their account on your own
service, and you have an Oauth
server, they can prompt them to
link their account.  They're
going to receive a card at the
top of their Google  Home map on
the phone that provides a link
to your login page.  They can
follow that, log in to your
service.  And they can invoke
your action and your action can
authenticate calls to your
services through our API.  So
it's important that you provide
the OAuth endpoint.  Right now
as part of the approval process
we basically want you to run
your own OAuth server.  So if
your experience involves
shopping or payments, we support
rich transactions and allow you
to accept user payments.  And
the really cool part is
customers can use whatever
payment information they have on
file with Google.  Payments can
be super easy.  No reason to
fumble around with a credit
card.  Although they can use
your payment solution if they
prefer.  Autosummary and
payments.  And the user can see
a history of
all their transactions.  The
Assistant also supports home
automation via our smart home
automation.  If you're a device
maker, you can easily integrate
your existing devices with the
home graph.  The home graph
knows the state of all the
connected devices.  When you're
asked to dim the lights, it does
that intelligencely.  There's
endless possibilitieses how to
interact with home automation.
We have announced the Google
Assistant SDK which enables you
to embed the Assistant in your
own custom hardware projects.
Magpie magazine with Google
provides a card board housing
with a button, a speaker and
wraps around a Ras berry PII.
And we demoed this mock tails
mix from our partner, Deep Local
, which embeds the S  did, K.
And you can tell it what kind of
drink you want and it will mix
it up for you.  You can embed
the Assistant pretty much into
any hardware device.
>> After we have built our
Assistant up, it's time to reach
the user and see how we can
drive traffic to it and what are
the different options for us at
the moment.  So the basic way
to invoke that is to -- after,
of course, you submitted the app
and it was
tested -- is to provide the set
of triggers that it knows.  So,
okay, Google, talk to -- in our
days -- Personal Chef, it could
be one or two different
invocations, and the user will
ask according to your brand name
or your app name and it will
invoke it.  We also support
deep-linking.  As you can see in
the example, in one sentence,
talk to the Personal Chef and
get the recipe or something else
.  There is also the ability to
ask Google  for -- I want to
work out.  I want yoga or
something more.  And obviously
if you have a quality good
Assistant up in the directory,
Google will surface it.  And
that's come to the point which
the blue ocean, great
opportunities there.
Last, but not least, we have a
full directory of apps that are
sitting and living inside the
Assistant.  On the top right
corner you have the ability to
click and open the directory.
And,  again, it's opening and
giving the user, based on
categories, and based on what
the Assistant thinks the user
will enjoy most -- what are the
different variations of apps
that are out there to try and
use?  There are quite a lot.  So
I really suggest you to check
some of them out.
You could and should link.  And
we have a deep link so if you
have a web service or another
app you could always link from
it to the Assistant app.  So in
lots of cases where the service
might be more efficient for your
users from the Assistant app, I
highly encourage you to link to
it, and then, of course, they
could use it.
>> So we've seen all this
awesome stuff you can do with
the actions platform, but let's
talk a little bit about how you
can get started.  So we've got a
series of videos that cover a
lot of content on how to get up
and running with the Assistant.
So we have an intro video that
explains high-level concepts and
goes through the Perm Chef
example.  And a video about
conversation design.  Worth
checking out as you start to
design and build your app.  And
we have a screencast of every
step needed to build our
Personal Chef example.  We have
several Code Labs that will help
you design and implement your
first Assistant app.  And
finally, when you want to
discuss this stuff with other
developers, we have a really
active action on Google
developer community.  We keep up
with the latest news and answer
questions from developers.  We
have a great community on Stack
overflow if you have technical
questions.
After us, there's a great talk
that will guide you in many more
detail how to build an
Assistant app.  Head upstairs
and check that out after this
talk.  And our whole team of
people are here.  So feel free
to come by and ask questions
about the platform.  We can show
you the Google Home and show
the Assistant SDK stuff.  Thank
you for coming and really
encourage you to dive into this
new platform.
[ Applause ]
>> Last, but not least, I forgot
to mention it at the beginning
-- I saw people taking photos.
All the slides are live.  You
would ping Dan or myself on any
channel that you wish.  And you
could get all the slides there.
And if you have any questions,
we'll be at our booth at the
Assistant app room.  So please
feel free to come over and give
us your  feedback and thoughts.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Cheers.
WOJTEK: Hello, everyone.  My
name is Wojtek.  I'm a developer
advocate working with the
Android Studio team.  And today
I want to tell you a little bit
about performance tooling that
we're releasing soon with the
new Android Studio version, 3.0.
And why
performance tooling?  Because I
think we all know perf matters,
right?  That's not something I
have to convince you developers
that's true.
So let me keep this intro short.
But I just want to tell you a
little bit how I understand app
performance and what it means to
me.  Imagine it's a measure of
your app quality.  A user
downloads the app and installs
it because they want to use
features.  The features that you
implemented, the benefits that
the app gives them.
You design a great UI because
you want the user to be able
so access information quickly
and you want them to -- you want
them to feel good about just
using your app.  Think about the
other part of the user
experience.  What if they want
to actually use it, but if
they're frustrated, because they
keep the app open and the
battery drains fast.  What if
just having the app installed
means their phone dies twice as
fast as before.  The user cares
about the responsiveness of the
device, a smooth
UI, about how fast the app
installs and how much space it
take up on the device.  And all
these things ultimately will
make your user happy or
frustrated because they're using
your app and ultimately it's
what they will feel about your
app and what rating they will
give you on the Play Store.
So whack we do about this as
developers?  I see it as a two-
way process.  You have to be
proactive and you have to be
reactive.  Now, what does it
really mean?  So even before you
start working on your app, you
have to plan for performance.
When developing before the
release, you have to keep
measuring and profiling.  What
does it mean that your app is
performant?  How can you know if
it's performing up to the
standards?  You have to actually
plan for some numbers.  Just do
some benchmarking.  Look at
your competitor's app.  See how
fast they work, how fast they
start.  Write down some figures
and plan for this.  Then, when
you relyse lease, maybe you will
not nail it the first time, but
you will have something to
strive for and to try and fix
it.  And then, be reactive.
This whole process doesn't end
when you release your app and
you're done.  No.  It's all
about monitoring and reacting to
any problems that arise.  And
you have to have tools to be
able to debug and fix these
things.
So today I'm going to talk a
little bit about the new Android
profiler.  Available in Android
Studio
3.0.  And this replaces the old
Android monitor tab.  You can
see when you launch your app on
a device or emulator, you open
the Android tab at the bottom
and see this view.  This is what
we call the unified timeline.
You can see three charts.  The
CPU, the memory, and the network
charts.  But what's really cool
about this view is here at the
top you can see an additional
track with some important app
events that are happening such
as input events, rotations and
activity state.  And looking at
these things gives you more
context to actually analyze the
data that you see below.
So imagine here I'm touching the
screen, interacting with my
app, and I can immediately see
on the CPU chart that my app is
doing something.  It's actually
processing the input events.
Then when I rotate, you can see
that activities are changing.
The activities are getting
destroyed and it's being created
and something is happening
there with the memory in CPU.
Now, when you click on the
tracks, you can go to a detailed
view.  And let's start with the
CPU profiler first.  The UI  is
a little bit complicated.  It
can be hard to see from the back
so let me walk you through the
main points here.  On the left,
these are all threads that were
active when you were profiling
the app using the CPU profiler.
And you can see a chart of
activity.  Spikes whenever there
was something happening in the
app such as activity creation,
swipes, list  scrolling and so
on.  And finally, you can see
thread state.  So you can see
which of the threads were active
and their associated
states such as if they were
sleeping, active, waiting, so
on.  And you can glance at this
and already figure out that
something's happening.  But the
nice thing is you can also start
method tracing from here using
this button.  Method tracing is
basically recording all the
method calls on the app so you
can analyze them better and
figure out which methods are
taking up the most time in your
app.
Now, there's two ways you can do
this.  This drop down next to
the report button.  You can
select the sample or instrument
to trace.  The difference is --
well, pretty small.  I mean,
they both essentially do the
same thing, except the sampled
one has a smaller overhead.  But
it can miss some very short
lived methods sometimes because
it  samples every X milliseconds
to check which methods were
run.  Whereas if you choose
instrument traces, they will
record every method enter and
exit.  But the overhead will be
bigger.  So what happens when I
press the start method tracing
button, I interact with my app.
I swipe on the screen.  I do
some transitions.  I rotate my
phone.  I press "Stop."  And
when Android Studio stops
processing the trace, you can
see this view.
So here at the bottom we see a
call chart from the selected
slice of time that you can see
on the timeline.  So here I
selected the moment when I was
rotating my phone and the
activity is getting destroyed
and re-created.  So imagine this
is an image gallery app.  And I
notice that when I'm  looking
at an image and I rotate my
phone, the activity takes an
unusually long time to actually
restart and show me the image
again.  So I want to see what's
happening there.  I can actually
zoom in this chart because I
want to see the exact calls that
were made.  Or I can just drag
and drop and select on the
timeline a smaller slice of that
recording of that trace.
And here at the bottom on the
call chart you can see all
Android framework methods
highlighted in yellow.  All
methods from my code that were
called in this trace in green.
And some other library methods
in blue.  So, again, for those
who can't see the small text on
the screen, here I can see the
whole oncreate method.  And
actually the width of the chart
show for how long the
representative methods were
running.  And the first thing
that runs in my oncreate is
layout inflation.  It takes some
time.  That's okay.  I can't do
anything about it.  But then I
notice there are two very long
method calls in my code that
actually create disk caches for
my images.  And first of all, I
can see that I'm actually
hitting the disk.  I'm creating
caches.  I'm reading disk from
my main thread.  I can see that
because I can see the thread
highlighted on the top on the
list.  All of this takes almost
twice the time it takes to
initialize my layout.  So I
should not be doing that in
oncreate.
And that's it.  In 10 seconds I
was able to quickly glance and
see what's happening in my
oncreate method and see what's
taking so long.  I recommend to
try this for all the places
where you need to finish
something quickly if you're
doing any calls in layouts -- in
computing layouts.  In custom
drawing for your  views.  Any
place, basically, that may be
impacted by doing
a lot of work on the CPU,
please check it out.
There's always -- also other
ways you can look at the data.
So the call chart is obviously a
very visual way to analyze it.
You can also open the top down
view and see all the calls from
are the thread route, from the
main method all the way down to
individual methods that were
called in your app.  And also
see some data, like relative
times of how long they ran.  And
there's another way of looking
at it.  In the bottom up view,
that's the second  tab, I can
actually sort all the methods
that were called by how long
they ran.  And I can immediately
see the method I was telling
you about, the create disk
caches method.  It's very high
on the list.  I can immediately
see that method is actually
making my oncreate slow.  And
then if I expand the nodes in
the preview, I can actually see
where it was called.  So instead
of going from the thread to the
individual methods, I'm going
the other way around.  Starting
with the method I'm interested
in and  finding out which place
in my
code I was calling it.
Okay.  So let's move on to the
memory profiler.  So here,
again, same situation.  I'm
rotating my screen.  Something's
being recomputed, re-created,
and my memory goes up.  You can
immediately see that from the
chart.  You can also see some
more events.  So you can see
when GC events were happening.
If you see too many of these
small trash can icons in a short
amount of time, and if the
memory is going up and down, up
and down, that means you might
be  flashing the memory.  You
might be creating objects and
destroying them, which, again,
might impact the performance of
your app.
Just for debugging, if you need
to force a garbage collection
event, you can do that from
here.  But the coolest part
about this memory view -- about
this memory analyzer is -- by
the way, this is all live.  I
know I'm presenting this on
screenshots, but this is all
going live when you run your
app.  And at any given moment
when you see something
interesting happening in many
your app, you can drag and drop
on the timeline and select a
slice of time without any pre-
recording any -- pressing any
buttons first.  And see all the
allocations and  de-allocations
that happened at that time.
So here you can see some input
events in the top.  This is a
situation where I was just
scrolling a long list of items.
Again, of images.  And you can
see -- just like I said --
memory goes up, memory goes
down.  There's a lot of garbage
collection events.  And for some
reason my scrolling is very
janky.  I can see the app is
loading something and just
thrashing memory.  So I'm
expecting this place for a
possible culprit.  And at the
bottom you can see a list of all
the classes that were either
allocated or de-allocated within
that time
slice.  But the really helpful
views are actually hidden under
a drop down.  So you can arrange
this data in different ways.
So here I
selected arrange by call stack.
And I can actually find the
place in my list adapter, the
get view method.  Which if you
remember, when you have a long
list, the adapter recycles views
and that has to provide them
whenever a new view has to be
shown on the screen when you
scroll it.  So I
found the get view method that
does exactly that.  And I can
see all the allocations that I'm
making there
.  And it turns out there's
actually a lot.  You can see the
number of allocations.  You can
see the memory sizes being
allocated.
Another way of looking at it is,
you can arrange by package.
Let's say I'm not interested by
third-party libraries.  I'm not
interested in other system
classes.  I'm only interested in
classes from my code.  So
something that I wrote that is
being allocated.  That's another
way to look at it.  So let's go
back to analyzing the get view
method.  So when you actually
select a class, you can see, on
the right, a new view opens and
you can see all instances or all
objects of that class that were
actually allocated and
de-allocated.  Even more, when
you select any of these objects,
you get a call stack.  So you
can see where -- exactly where
that object was allocated.  So
you can track down these rogue
allocations and try and fix it
somehow.  Maybe move it to some
warmup before or just some
shared cache.
Another thing you can do with
the memory analyzer is you can
analyze heat dumps.  So whenever
you want to examine a state in
your app -- let's say you were
using your app.  You were just
using it as a normal user would,
and something's wrong.  You got
the app into a weird state.
Maybe some view is not showing,
maybe some image is not loading.
And you want to figure out
what's going on.  Or you want to
figure out, where is all that
memory coming from?  All these
memory allocations?  What
objects actually exist in my
app?  So just press this button,
wait a bit, and then you get a
similar view as before.  Except
now you have a snapshot of
memory from your app at the time
when you pressed the button.
So, again, you have a list of
classes.  You can click on it.
And you get a list of instances
of objects of those classes.
And here the view looks slightly
different.  For every instance
you can actually analyze all the
fields, all the values that
were held there just as if you
were
debugging the app in Android
Studio.
So this is nice for figuring out
the state of the object.  But
if you have another problem --
if you know you have a memory
leak, and, for example, you see
an object that shouldn't be
there.  Let's say it's some
activity that you actually
stopped interacting with a long
time ago and it should really be
garbage collected by now, but
it's still there in the list,
you can use the bottom view
here -- the references view --
to figure out who is holding
references to my view?  Who is
preventing it from being garbage
collected?  And here by
expanding the nodes, you can
find a chain of references.
Usually to the Window object or
--
And finally, the last profiler,
network  profiler.  So this view
is quite interesting because
you can see -- you can use it
for two purposes.  Analyzing
network requests, obviously.
But the other one is -- it
actually shows you the radio
power state and you can figure
out battery problems that might
be created by your app.  So the
radio state can be shown in
three states, really.  It's
either Wi-Fi, low powered radio,
or
high-powered radio.  And the
way the GSM radio on your
devices works, when it doesn't
have to do any transmissions,
when you're not downloading or
uploading data, it can go to a
low powered state to save
battery life.  As soon as you
want to make a request -- if
your app has to hit the network
-- the radio has to be powered
up.  That already takes up some
battery.  Then you make your
request and then it stays up for
some time just in case you want
to request some more data from
the network.
And that can be wasteful.  But
you can actually minimize that,
in fact, by batching your
requests.  And if you look here
-- if you look at your
incomer profiler after using it
for a while, after  interacting
with it, you can see if your
requests were batched in one
place.  And you're downloading,
and then the radio can go to a
low-powered state.  Or if you
were waking the radio up every
minute, every 30 seconds, and
then figure out how to fix it.
Obviously the profiler is not
only
about the radio state and the
battery, it's all about network.
At the bottom you see the data
transfer graph.  You see how
much data was sent.  When the
requests were made.  And, again,
like on the previous profilers,
you can select a chunk of time
and then see all the HTTP and
HTTPS requests that were made in
that time.  It's a little bit
similar to
Devtools that you know from,
for example, the content type.
You can see a timeline with how
long a request -- the time that
every request took.  But even
more, if you click on any of
these, you can see the actual
payload.  So if it was an image,
like a JPEG or a PNG.  Text,
such as JSON on HTML, you can
see what was downloaded into
your app through that request.
And you can see HTTP headers,
very useful for debugging
problems with server APIs.  And
finally, you can see the call
stack showing you where the call
was made in your code.
So that's pretty useful.  A few
comments.  The profilers work
great on Android Oreo.  You
don't have to literally do
anything.  They should just work
with any debugable A, K.  They
work on lower AI versions.  But
on
nougat and below, you have to
build from Android Studio to use
the profilers.  And enable
advanced profiling.  If you
don't have it enabled, don't
worry.  The profiler will show a
prompt and it will literally be
a one-click fix.  And there are
small differences in how
profilers work.  So, for
example, in Nougat and below, to
track, you have to press a
record button just like on the
CPU chart.  Other than that,
most functions should be
available for you.
And there is one more new thing
in Android Studio 3.0.  Is there
any, for example, game
developers out there?  Or people
who use alternative ways to
build your a, PKs such as
different
IDs or a different tool chain
and you would like to use the
Android profiler or just use
Android Studio to debug the app.
There's a new profile type to
debug external APKs.  You can
select this from the Android
Studio launcher.  The first
screen you see.  Select your APK
and it a dummy project will be
created for you with the APK
attached.  With the Java code
decompiled and you can even see
the APK contents and the
analyzer for you.  And you can
do that to load an external APK.
And you can attach Java
sources and native libraries
with debug symbols that let you
do step-by-step debugging.
And if you wanted to try
Android Studio for debugging,
try it out.
The window on the right, it's
not new in Android Studio,
however, Android Studio 3.0
brings some pretty notable
improvements.  The way you
launch is you can select analyze
APK from the build menu.  One
word of advice, if you build
your
APKs using Android Studio, they
don't contain all the classes
and resources
you want to look at and
analyze.  Instead
, press the build APK or
generate.  Wait until APK builds
and you will get a nice
generation.  APK is ready and
you can open it here or on the
analyzer.  Press analyzer.  If
the analyzer goes through.  Just
a short walk through.  It's
been in Android Studio for a
time.
And you can see the basic info
such as the file sizes of the
APK, file size, the download
size because Play Store
compresses the APK for delivery
to devices.  And then you can
get to the classes that are in
the class files and resources.
What we've added in Android
Studio 3.0, you can now see a
third column showing you the
size of the decks -- of the
decks in your APKs.  So you can
actually see the size of a
package, the size of a class,
and even the size that a method
adds to your class' next files.
So it's pretty good for
figuring out where all that
space is going to.
But there's a new thing I wanted
to announce today.  And just
last night we updated the
Android  apk tools and we are
now offering
the APK analyzer as a command
tile for using your CI servers.
[ Applause ]
So this was a long-standing
request.  I'm happy we are
finally ready to preview.  I'm
hoping you'll try it out.  It
does most of the things and even
more than the APK analyzer in
Android Studio.  The syntax is
pretty basic.  It has commands
that let you inspect things in
the manifest, in the APK, in the
deck size and print out
resources from the resource
table.  It will be great for
generating reports on your build
servers.  It will be great for
comparing to APK versions to see
where your request when it
comes to APK size.  And with
some script through, you can
even figure out very, very
specific changes in your APK
such as you take two APKs, list
all the packages inside, all the
classes.  And you notice that
between these two versions some
developer in your project added
two new classes and they take up
X amount of space in those
APKs.
So these are only some ideas on
how you can use them.  I'm
curious to hear your feedback on
this tool.  So please come to
see me after this session and
let's talk.
And the last thing I wanted to
mention in this session is
Android Vitals.  So this is a
place in the Android -- in the
Google
-- that let's you track and
feed some common problems with
your apps happening on user's
devices.  Such as ANR rate --
application not responding.
This basically happens whenever
you use network or storage for
the main thread.  You can see
the crash rate.  You can figure
out things like slow rendering
or frozen frames.   Which
usually means you're doing
something wrong with the CPU or
memory as I showed you you can
analyze before.
And finally,s wait logs and
excessive wakeups which have an
impact on the user's battery
life.  We also offer all this
information on developers
Android com.  Every section has
a dedicated page that explains
all the tools and debug methods
that you can use to figure out
these things and fix them in
your apps.  So I really
encourage you to look it up in
the Play Store, in the Play
Console, and start working on
it.
So thank you very much.  I'll be
here on level three in the
Android office hours booth.  If
you want to talk about the new
profilers and the APK analyzer,
please come talk to me.  And I'm
curious to hear what you think.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
JUAN: Hello, everyone.  My name
is Juan Silveira.  I'm a
software engineer in the health
team.  And I'm here to tell you
a little bit about DeepMind and
the work we have been doing.  So
let me start by telling you who
we are.  DeepMind is a British
artificial intelligence company
that was founded in 2010 and
joined forces with Google in
2014.  We're an unusual company
in that we have a two-part
mission.   The first part of
that mission is to create
general artificial intelligence.
Now, what do we mean by
"General artificial
intelligence"?  And the key here
is being able to create agents,
algorithms, that can work and
do well in a variety of tasks
and environments.  And the key
to that is to get them to learn
from their own experience.  So
not to pre-program them with
behaviors, but to actually allow
them to learn from what they
can see in their environment.
So that's the first part of our
mission.  But we also have a
second part, which is to use
artificial general intelligence
to address pressing social
challenges.  So we recognize the
potential for AGI to really
make a change in the world.  And
we want to make sure that that
is the -- the  benefits of that
reach everyone and they can use
it to address things that we, as
a society, have to deal with.
So how -- that's our mission.
How were we actually formed?  We
are at heart a research
orientation.  Based in London,
King's Cross.  And we have 300
of the best AI research
scientists in the world here in
Europe.  We, like any research
extension, we do our research in
the open.  So we actually
publish over a hundred papers on
different research.  And we
joined forces with Google in
2014 so that we could really
take our speed up to the next
level.  And the mixture of these
two things means we're a bit of
a hybrid organization.  On the
one hand, we have the really
very long-term focus of academia
.  Because AGI  is not something
that's going to happen any time
soon.  But we're very, very
focused on making that happen.
But at the same time we have the
pace, the scale and the agility
of a very well-funded startup.
And because of the second part
of our mission, we also have a
lot of people in our
organization that have the kind
of social impact values that you
only find generally in the
public sector.  Now, I talked
about AGI, artificial general
intelligence.  How is that we're
trying to resolve this?  And
we're trying to resolve this by
building general purpose
learning systems.  And this --
just to give you an idea --
involves creating agents that
interact with an environment.
So these agents get signals and
make observations of the
environment.  And decide on
actions to take that then get
reflected into that environment.
And once they have taken those
actions, they can actually
observe again how that affects
the environment.  But the key
thing is that they have a goal.
A function that tells them
whether they're closer to
actually achieving what it is
that they're trying to do.  And
this whole process is called
deep reinforcement learning.
I'm sure some of you have heard
about
it and it's key to what we're
doing at DeepMind.
The environment that we use for
this is key.  And we've already
had quite a bit of success using
the older ones as a test bed,
as an environment on which to
train agents, Atari games.  We
have taken over a hundred games,
thing like Pong, Frogger,
Breakout.  Some games I'm sure
many of you have  played.  And
in the environment, what the
agent  sees, the inputs, are
just the pixels on the screen.
So just gets a matrix of pixels.
Not the values that you would
see on the screen.  And the
outputs are the controllers,
which are simple controls.  So
up, down, left, right and
trigger buttons.  But the really
important thing is that the
agent is not told what to do.
So it's not told the rules of
the different games.  It's not
told, like, how it works.  Like
what are the internal function
of the Atari game.  So any
knowledge needs to be learned
from scratch with serial
pre-programming.  Like no
strategies how to play the
different games.  We give it a
goal.  And that is to
maximize the score.
But the key thing that I think
is fantastic when I first
learned about this was that one
agent plays all of the game.  So
you don't train one agent for
each game, you train one agent
in all of the games and have it
play all of the games.  So a
good analogy of how this works
is that you could have a little
robot in an arcade sitting in
front of the game looking at the
screen and moving the
controller.  That's all.  It
doesn't have any knowledge of
the internal works.
So let me show you how this
looks like.  As the agent is
being trained on how it evolves.
So this is the game of
Breakout.  I'm sure many of you
have played.  How many of you
have played Breakout  before?
Great.  I won't explain it.  So
the agent starts -- it starts
training.  After half an hour,
it doesn't really know what's
happening.  So just loses quite
quickly.  Sometimes it manages
to bounce the ball back.  Mostly
just loses quite quickly.
After an hour of training, it
gets a little bit better.  It's
like, maybe survives two
bounces.  But that's about it.
It actually still loses quite
quickly.  But after two hours,
it's now doing how you would do
probably if you started playing
Breakout right now.  Runs
around, bounces the ball back
and manages a basic level of
competence.  But the great thing
is what happened unexpectedly
after we let it play for four
hours and the agent started
doing this.
[ Laughter ]
So for those of you that have
actually played  Breakout for
some time, you learned this is a
winning strategy.  Break the
sides and push the ball up to
the top and it just does the
work for you.  But this is not
something that was
pre-programmed on the system.
It's not something that we told
the agent about.  It's something
that the agent  discovered by
playing the game thousands and
thousands of times with this
goal function of improving the
score.  And this is a
power of deep reinforcement
learning that allows these kinds
of behaviors to emerge.
So we use the Atari games for a
long time for research.  And we
still use them today.  We
published papers about this
research.  It was quite
successful.  But a few years ago
there was a team at DeepMind
that started looking for a new
challenge.  And that challenge
was the game of Go.  Let's see
if I can --
So for those of you that don't
know Go, it's a very ancient
game originated in China about 3
,000 years ago.  And it's
considered by many to be more
than just a game.  It's --
people think about it as a
spiritual dimension as poetry or
art.  It was considered to be
one of the four arts that were
key to being mastered by a true
scholar.  It is hugely popular
in many places, especially in
Asia.  There's 40 million
players, 2,000 professional
players.  And there's schools
throughout Japan, south Korea
and China.  And the thing about
Go, why it's a great challenge,
is because it has very simple
rules
.  You can learn the rules of Go
in a couple of minutes.  But
from those rules arises a huge
profound complexity.  To give
you the idea of a scale, there's
an estimate that there's about
10 to the 80 number of atoms in
the universe.  But there are 10
to the 170 possible board
configurations in Go.  So it's
impossible to play Go by brute
forcing or  trying to explore
all of that
possibility space with no good
strategy.  And that means that
Go has been one of the great
challenges for AI, because no
computer program could beat a
professional -- human
professional Go player.
If you compared this to chess,
which is something that computer
programs have been doing well
for a while, the number of
possible moves at any time in
chess is 20.  And in Go, it's
over it00.  So the team at
DeepMind started creating
artificial intelligence program
that's alled Alpha Go.  And
Alpha Go is composed of two
neural networks.  You have the
policy network and the value
network.  And the policy network
was initially trained using
human games.  So we
took thousands of games from an
online  Go server that we had
access to and trained this
network by watching those games.
And then trained it further by
playing against itself.  And the
objective of the policy network
is to given a particular
configuration of the board, to
say which positions are most
likely to be played next.  And
that allows you to
narrow down that branching
factor.  The other network --
the value network -- takes the
configuration of the board and
what it tries to estimate is how
likely is white or black to
win?  So instead of having to
actually play out the entirety
of the game to try to figure out
who is most likely to win, this
allows us to cut down how deep
you need to go in order to
explore the possibilities.
[ Applause ]
>> Wow. That's pretty cool.
Two days of  learning.  Two days
conversation.  I can't believe
it's over.  Can you?
It's like it just started.
And we aspired to create a
conference for all of you that
is more than just a technology
show.  We  aspired it to be
European, to be a place of
learning, and to be an inclusive
place where you can get
inspired and have conservations
and just love being a developer
around a developer crowd.
So when you design something
like this, there are a couple of
things that you try to get
right.  And then you wonder if
you really got it right.  So
being a place of learning, kind
of easy, right?  You ask the
audience -- in that case, you,
developers, what would you like
to hear?  Invite experts, get
sessions, put on an agenda, find
a place.  Check.  And after the
event we ask how we did and how
we can improve.  Being a
European conference, also kind
of easy.  So in this room we are
actually more than European.
We are a global conference.  We
have 71 nations sitting in the
room, and more than two-thirds
of you come from countries
outside of Poland.  So this is
truly an international European
concerns and that is what I
heard from you all over the
place.  Among the good
conversations, you liked the
perspectives from people from
other countries.  The inclusive,
inspiring part is a tricky
piece.
Because, well, how do you test
for that?  There are a million
little things you can do and
try, and it's not easy to test.
Some would say it's more a soft
thing.  But wait a minute, we
can ask,
right?  So I can -- I can run a
little experiment.  Maybe you
do it with me.  I am going to
raise my hand, and everybody who
feels, like, inspired being --
learned something new and being
part of an inclusive conference
just start cheering.  How about
that?  Let's try.
[ Applause ]
That was like medium-size cheer.
And it was kind of expected.
So if you look around and you
were some -- in the cheering
crowd, you might have noticed
some of you didn't cheer.
Because,  actually, we Europeans
don't cheer that easily.  Just
because some clown on stage says
cheer, we don't cheer.  And
that -- that is kind of a --
that's a well known stereotype.
Actually, we, as Europeans,
subscribe to that stereotype.
Others believe it and Europeans
believe it and do it themselves.
And these kinds of stereotypes
we know.  There are like a
million other things that are
unconsciously baked into how we
behave, how we make decisions.
Now, we are engineers.  So it's
like a decision through your
filter, if you will.  Our brains
are remarkably good at that
because that  helps us
navigating the world faster than
we would without these
heuristics, if you will.
So these unconscious
stereotypes, these unconscious
biases, they influence how you
make products, how you make
decisions.  The conference is a
product, if you will.  Software
is a product.  Hardware -- you
build products out of these
elements.  And your stereotypes
influence your decisions.  Your
conscious and unconscious biases
influence your decisions.  By
extension, sometimes, they
influence what kind of product
you build.
We, at Google, we build products
that have a global scale.  We
want everyone to be part of this
technology build that we are
all creating together.  How do
we build processes?  How do we
design software?  How do we
design systems that are --
without realizing, without
wanting it -- maybe  biased as
well?  Our biases creep in.  And
if you take an example of this
had conference, this was an
important question when we
started building up the project
team and started working towards
these two amazing days we just
had.
So we brought -- and we thought,
in this last session of this
two day conference, we talk a
little bit about how Google
tries to build software in a way
that's more inclusive.  What
are the processes?  What are the
practices?  What are the things
that we try to do in order to
overcome that challenge?  So
please welcome to the stage
engineering lead at YouTube,
Sowmya Subrama.
[ Applause ]
SOWMYA: Thank you, Kirk.  I'm
super-excited to be here.  I
still remember my first
technical conference
presentation.  Almost 17 years
ago in Paris.  Where I, the
speaker, was pretty much the
only female engineer in the
whole room.  To see so many
women engineers at this
conference has been amazing.  We
have come a really long way.
And let's give a big round of
applause to that.
[ Applause ]
As Dirk mentioned, I'm an
engineering director at YouTube
and I will be showing a lot of
YouTube videos in my
presentation.  So let's start
off with a video of a favorite
clip of mine.
>> Cookie!
[ Applause ]
SOWMYA: Oh!  The video's not
playing on screen.
I can see it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Okay.
SOWMYA: All right.  Okay.  Shall
we get this started again?
Yes.  So sorry about the
projection not showing up.  It's
a video you're going to enjoy,
I promise.  So let's start with
the video.  Is it progressing?
[ Laughter ]
It's not?
[ Applause ]
SOWMYA: Are we doing the voice
of God?  Okay.  All right.
Let's see if this works.  This
is how we debug problems in
Google.  Let's try it.
[ Applause ]
Yes!
[Music
playing]
This is --
[ Applause ]
So this is a clip from my
all-time favorite YouTube rewind
videos from 2015.  Because it
really captures the essence of
YouTube.  YouTube started out
with a very simple mission:
broadcast yourself.  And it has
grown into a global platform
with global reach.  We have over
1.5 billion users coming to
YouTube every month.  And over
80% of our views come from
outside the United States.  We
are an open and democratic
platform with over 400 hours of
videos being uploaded every
minute by creators all around
the world.  Making YouTube the
platform with the most diverse
content.
In the time that it took me to
say this sentence, or for us to
debug that problem earlier,
almost a full day's worth of
videos have been  uploaded to
YouTube.  What makes YouTube
special is that unlike
traditional media or television,
we have no gatekeepers.  Anyone
can have a voice and reach and
build an audience.  While this
is still very, very true about
YouTube, a few years ago when I
was looking at some usage data
on YouTube, I realized that as
our platform and usage have
grown, human dynamics and
unconscious biases -- like what
Dirk was talking about -- are
creeping in.  And on
YouTube, too, we see biases and
gender gaps, for instance, like
traditional media.
On YouTube, too, we see a lot of
our makeup videos, for
instance, are created by female
creators.  And a lot of the
science and engineering and
technology videos are made by
male creators.  With this in
sight, I started a conservation
and a pitch within YouTube and
across Google at large whose
mission is to build products for
all about diversity in the
context of product design.  And
how does
unconscious bias play into
product engineering?
What if -- in YouTube -- in
addition to optimizing for the
growth of watch time, we became
more intentional about our
demographic goals.  Such as
gender reach or ethnicity reach.
That would unlock
opportunities for deeper
engagement and onboard more
users, thereby driving growth.
So for the first time at Google,
we extended our dialogues
around diversity at Google from
being about hiring and building
balanced teams, to about
diversity becoming a core piece,
to defining the growth
strategies for all our products.
And that brings me to today's
topic of inclusive design as a
growth accelerator.
So what is inclusive design?
It's about engineering products
for all your target users across
all demographics.  When you
broaden your demographic reach,
you're increasing your user
funnel and thereby driving
growth for your products.
Inclusive design is not just
about user design or visual
design, it is also about machine
learning and algorithms.  About
the training data.  About
testing.  About how you launch
the product.  The branding.
Marketing.  And more.  Inclusive
design is about asking which
target user segments could you
be doing more for?  It could be
gender-based.  It could also be
that your products work great
when you have good connectivity.
But then doesn't work that
well in the developing world.
It could be about optimizing
your products for certain
ethnicity
groups.  As an industry, we all
have been doing inclusive
design for lots of years now in
the form of accessibility work.
And this is about expanding
that across other dimensions.
For instance, when airbags first
came out, there were more
deaths and injuries in women and
kids.  Why?  Because airbags
were tested with only tall, male
crash test dummies.
Were the engineers who
designed this sexist?  No.  It's
because of the unconscious
biases that informed their
process.  Female drivers tend to
have a smaller build.  And in
real crashes have 47% higher
chance of severe injuries than
men.  So once the industry
included women in their design
and started using female crash
test dummies, the safety of
airbags went up significantly
for women.  And not just for
women, but for anyone with a
smaller build.
So this is an example of
gender-based inclusive design.
Airbags still don't work well
for kids, and that is an
opportunity of growth.  For this
next example that I want to
show you, I'll start with the
video.
[ Laughter ]
So anyone know what's going on
there?  For this we need to go
back to the 1950s when Kodak was
dominating color photography.
And they introduced the Shirley
color card which has become the
standard for all photography.
But it works better with
lighter skin tones.  So what
this means is, you often have
exposure issues when taking
multi-racial photos.  This
problem was recognized as a big
problem in the 1970s when
chocolate makers and wood
manufacturers were having a hard
time creating advertising
material for their products
because they could not capture
in photos the different shades
of brown.  So a funny way for
this problem to get surfaced.
It also was becoming an
increasing problem in the media
and television world was
starting to become more diverse.
Finally, 25 years later, in
1995, a group of engineers took
an inclusive design approach to
help bridge this gap.  And they
launched multi-racial color
cards which have significantly
improved camera and
photo technology and helped
unlock a lot of advertising
revenue and new business
opportunities.
While things have improved,
there's still a slight light-had
skinned bias, which is what you
saw in the video earlier.  The
black color skin is not
recognized by the camera, which
is why, when the black person
was moving, it seems so stable.
But the face recognition was
able to follow along with the
white-skinned person.  I'm
really proud that at Google
we've taken a proactive
, inclusive design approach to
helping bridge this gap.  And
the Google camera team is
helping solve this problem.
Let's watch a video on what the
camera team has done.
[ Applause ]
SOWMYA: All right.  So this next
example, how many of you know
of Cheeto?  A few.  Cheese
puffs?  Or cheese -- the cheesy
snacks.  It's a very American
snack, called Cheeto.  And when
it first came out, it was only
available in one flavor.  The
cheesy flavor.  Cheese flavor.
Until a janitor who worked for
the company started adding chili
and lime to his pacts of Cheeto
to make it more flavorful for
him.  He was Latino and loved
chili and lime.  His family and
friends also liked the taste.
So he decided to pitch this new
flavor idea to the president of
the company who actually
listened to this janitor and
decided to experiment with this
new flavor.  And that unlocked
huge opportunities and markets
for
Cheetos.  I'm happy to say the
janitor is now an executive at
the company.  It's a true  rags
to riches story.  And more
importantly, it's a story that
shows cultural inclusive design
thinking.
This next example is from
YouTube.  A few years ago, we
wanted to increase engagement
with kids and families on
YouTube.  So we brought kids
into our UX lab to see how do
they use and interact with
YouTube?  This is what we see.
Yeah?  Everyone uses YouTube
here?  Yes.  Many.  This is what
we see.  But the kids, when
they saw the same thing, this is
how they saw it.  They didn't
care about anything else on the
screen other than the video
content that was there.  That is
when we realized if we wanted
to increase engagement with kids
and families, we had to
reimagine YouTube from the
ground up and build a new app.
And that's when YouTube Kids App
was born.  The YouTube Kids App
provides easy to use
interactivity and safe,
enriching and engaging content
for kids and families.  And
we've done this by improving our
user design and visual design
and user interactions.  And also
by making a lot of changes to
our algorithms, the backend
systems, and our content
classification
systems.
YouTube Kids now has over 11
million weekly  active users.
And we see the engagement with
kids and family content on the
YouTube Kids App to be
significantly more than on main
YouTube.  This is a great
example of age-based inclusive
design driving growth.  It also
demonstrates, clearly, that
sometimes for you to meet the
needs of specific target user
demographics, you might have to
build a specialized product for
them.  How many of you have used
a YouTube Kids App?  Hardly
any.  Okay.  Because we haven't
launched in all the markets yet.
So I'm going to play the first
launch video of YouTube Kids
App for you to get an idea of
what I'm talking about.  Let's
roll the video.
[ Applause ]
SOWMYA: So how many of you use
emojis?  Yeah.  You are not
alone.  90% of the world's
online population also uses
emoji
s.  Why there are many emojis to
choose from, they're fairly
stereo  typical.  The boys are
doctors or police and others.
And the girls are queens and
princesses and giving haircuts
to people.  So it's fairly
stereotypical.  So bridge that
gap and to also be inspiring for
young girls, Google has added a
whole new set of emojis to
represent women and men in
diverse roles.  And in a mix of
hair and skin colors to be more
inclusive.  This is driving
industry-wide change with iOS,
Facebook, Twitter and others
embracing these new set of
emojis in their products and
platforms.  This is a great case
of gender-based and ethnicity-
based inclusive design.
[ Applause ]
This next example is, again,
from YouTube.  How many of you
have heard of women harassment
in online communities?  Like the
gaming community, through
hashtags and online commenting
tools?  Some of you.  Yeah.
Many of you might have heard of
Gamergate where women gamers
were even threatened for their
lives using these online
commenting tools.
A few years ago in YouTube, we
organized a women at YouTube
hack-a-thon around the theme of
bridging the gender gap to drive
grassroots momentum around
inclusive design.  One of the
salient projects in this
hack-a-thon focused on improving
YouTube comments to help women
combat harassment and feel safer
on YouTube.  As a result of
this  hack-a-thon project, we
have launched several
enhancements to YouTube comments
and our moderation tools such
as making it easier for creators
to deal with inappropriate
comments, blacklist words, and
also limit commenters who are
making those inappropriate
comments.
This is a great example of
gender-based inclusive design
thinking to further deepen our
engagement with our female
creators.  It also shows that
many times grassroots ideas like
hack-a-thons can bring about
change in many product direction
and strategy.
So now I've gone through several
examples of different kinds of
inclusive design.  Some from the
non-technology world, and many
from the technology world and
many from Google and YouTube.
And now I want to talk about how
do you do inclusive design at
scale
and become more proactive
rather than  reactive.  These
are the project at Google, not
linear.  These are the stages we
go through during product
design and development.  In
Google we are starting to become
more intentional about setting
demographic goals at every stage
of product development.  So
when we are defining target
users, instead of just saying
18-34 age group, we are also
picking a demographic goal that
we would like to meet.  So we're
saying, 18-34 age group with
equal engagement from male and
female.  Or, 18-34 age group
with this level of ethnic reach
that
we want to get on the platform.
Once we've set that demographic
goal, we propagate is through
the rest of the stages of
product development.  So when
we're doing testing, for
instance, we are very careful in
picking our test user groups to
ensure that they are reflecting
and mirroring the demographic
goals that we want to meet.
Whether it is with user research
and user testing or training
data for machine learning or
market research or more.  Over
the last two days you've heard
that Google is a lot about
algorithms and machine learning.
And you could ask, like,
machines -- why are they biased?
They should all be like
neutral.  And that's not the
case.  There are lots of
different kinds of biases that
can come into your machine
learning systems too.  And I
want to roll a video, now, to
show you what those different
biases are and how we are
tackling it at Google.  Let's
roll the video.
[ Applause ]
SOWMYA: Once you have designed
the product and you're ready to
launch, it's really important
that your marketing, branding,
and support systems all are
making sure to echo the
demographic goals that you set
out with.  Now, for inclusive
design to be a success, in
addition to everything that we
talked about just now, it's
really important to still have
diverse perspectives and diverse
teams.  And to increase the
representation of diversity in
technology.  So to this end,
Google is investing, through our
computer science education and
media efforts, to increase the
access of technology education
around the world to a diverse
group.  And to help increase
awareness of unconscious biases.
And also partnering with
Hollywood and other media
producers to change how
scientists and engineers and
computer scientists are
portrayed on the big screen.
Because that can be a huge
influencer.  So another video,
the last one in this
presentation, showing what we
are doing with the media work.
Let's roll the video.
>> Is really a tool.
>> Growing up, I was --
[ Applause ]
SOWMYA: So now it comes to you.
I hope I've shown you today the
value of inclusive design and
how you can drive growth using
inclusive design.  I hope also
that I've shown you the ways in
which Google is doing inclusive
design.  And what are some of
the steps that we are taking by
becoming more intentional?  Now,
you -- when you go back --
leave this room, go back to your
offices -- can follow the same
similar approach that Google is
doing.  I would also like to
leave you with a cheat sheet.
Right?  The first thing is in
your current products, it'll be
great if you can identify
demographic gaps that you have.
And the magnitude of these
gaps, and if you were to bridge
them, what kind of impact they
could be driving.  Once you have
that, prioritize which gap --
the one gap that you want to
fill because we are all resource
constrained and can't solve
anything.  Pick one or two gaps
and drives the biggest impact
for you.  As you bridge those
gaps, make sure you have metrics
and logging and data to measure
progress.  And
when you drive big impact,
celebrate your wins.
Also
, it's really important to
foster an inclusive culture in
your organizations.  You can do
hack-a-thons around inclusive
design teams to drive more
energy and momentum across your
entire team.  You can also do
unconscious bias trainings to
make more people aware in your
whole organization.  So with
that, now, I want you to take a
moment and think about the one
thing you're going to do
differently when you leave this
room.  And if you want to be
bold, you can Tweet
it @googledevs and mark it with
the #
GDDeurope and women tech makers.
Anyone to want shout out an
idea they might be doing
differently?  It's okay.
Anyone?
[ Applause ]
All right.  Okay.  So with that
-- okay.  So with that I'm going
to invite Dirk back to wrap up.
And I hope you enjoyed the
session.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you. And I believe --
I need to do this.  There have
been a few people having quite
an adrenaline rush back there.
And Sowmya certainly had the
same, I think.  Even Europeans
can give them an extra cheer,
right?  Come on.
[ Applause ]
You know, that's like a
nightmare.  So I was really
feeling with her.  The last step
on our two day's journey for me
is now to say a very warm thank
you.  It has been incredible
two days and we have a few
parting wishes.  You heard
Sowmya's wish, I have an
additional.  Please, don't be a
stranger.  There are several
ways to stay in touch with each
other and with us.  Continue the
conversation that you take with
you out of this conference.
The women tech makers, the GDGs.
It's kind of hard if you have
walked the halls not to have
bumped into them.  Maybe you are
a member already, maybe you are
interested.  Stay in touch.
On your way out, there are -- on
the entrance, I have been told
-- a couple thing use might
consider grabbing.  Apparently
there's some swag left.  If you
keep your eyes open, might be
interesting what you see.  And
with that, please travel safely.
Thank you for being with us
today.  And -- yeah.  Maybe next